mais venus à sans fil dans le podcast on
parle de ce conte avec nos invités à
rentrer avec mort d'homme plan cette
semaine
grand honneur pour nous de recevoir
patrick senécal un auteur légende a au
québec on pourrait un peu dire que c'est
le stephen king du québec certains
quelqu'un de jeu thomas des légendaires
qu'on voulait vraiment rencontré que tu
as not least depuis le début du podcast
qu'un qui on voulait parler qui a été
par la barre en effet lui comparé par
son fils tout à fait se rendent jusqu'à
lui est venue avec plaisir puis il ya eu
beaucoup plaisir ce qui nous unit après
justement qu'est tripes et nous parler
cinéma de parler littérature beaucoup en
italie en profondeur dans ces heures
dans sa psychologie à lui dans le
phénomène et des films des livres
d'horreur tout ce juste une diction des
plus passionnantes moi j'ai vraiment
adoré puis c'est mais pas de casse
préféré qu'on estime ouais on vient tout
juste de finir le tour mais puisque
encore un peu sous le choc de la
conversation qu'on est d'avoir pour vrai
j'espère que vous allez messieurs autant
que nous si j'ai même pas envie de te
rien ploguer 11 réel laissez-nous des
commentaires ajoutés à la conversation
abonnez-vous à notre chaîne si vous
voulez vous pouvez supporter sur pétrole
mais principalement à ce que vous portez
une attention à ce qu'il ya à la
conversation qui va suivre donc non pas
de castres bonne écoute
c'est parti c'est une conversation qui
depuis qu'on a commencé par lequel j'ai
le plus sorte d'avoir mon dieu vraiment
je suis je suis c'est un horaire et le
nom de te recevoir chez nous il rouvre
s&t une figure marquante pour le québec
en général puis je pense qu'on te pas
entendu assumer t'exprimer par rapport à
ton parcours par rapport à ton à la
façon avec laquelle tu abordes
l'écriture mais non seulement sur la
façon avec laquelle est capable de
tisser paraît un petit peu de thé de tt
histoire la façon dont tu es capable de
ne pas entretenir l'espèce d'image du
poète maudit qui qui vit dans un chalet
pour écrire de l'horreur ça je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui est ultra
intéressant puis j'ai juste à tomber
dans le vif du sujet tout démystifier la
première fois que je t'ai vu tu es à ton
monde en parle
parlez en entrevue je me rappelle m'être
dit m chose qu'il détonne réellement
entre cette personne là et son oeuvre
parle en 2007 ou
je suis allé deux fois 2007 en 2007
parce que ouais ça devait être en 2007
quand j'étais au secondaire je me
rappelle ma vie est vraiment quelque
chose qui détonne en la personne que je
vois dans moi puisque j'ai lu de cette
personne-là puis si j'ai toujours trouvé
ce fascinant c'est quelque chose qui est
activement activement tu es conscient de
j'en suis conscient parce que le monde
me dit mais je cultive pas seulement
quelqu'un qui se dit le fou que je pense
qu'en général les écrivains qui veulent
cultiver une image
il cultive l'image qui va avec ce qui
est écrit donc si je voulais me
préoccuper de ça je serais plutôt dark
je me donnerais le godsick
jaradi avec ma très sombre un peu bon
fait que non en fait ces dirigeants qui
en camp parce que moi moi j'ai toujours
été un gars qui aime rire qui aime
rigoler un but qui peut très préoccupé
par son look et tout ça donc je quand
j'ai commencé à écrire puis mes premiers
romans étaient pas juge pas devenu
quelqu'un de connu ce premier coup le
ticket des écrivains qui vient connu du
premier roman pour se rebeller c'est
difficile de rester à ma place moi ça
monte tranquillement comme ça monte
tranquillement
elle allait commander la popularité puis
montez que le projeter roja est venu
tranquillement aussi parce que je ne
sais pas faire connaître premier coup
d'envoi un salon du livre cash devenu
pas mal connu elle leur est pas suivie
respectivement l'offre fais attention tu
es gentil connu que moi je ne voyais pas
la nécessité de changer je reste
elle-même gorge est bon ici c'est dans
les salons du livre que de plus en plus
des gens commençaient à me dire plus que
je t'ai connu puisqu'il ne faisait pas
on s'attendait vraiment pas qu'on
appelle les premières fois que je me
suis fait dire ça dans des salons du
livre me rappelle ce sera des gothiques
il n'aime voir qui doit-être les femmes
avec des d'équité des fruits qui sont
des fans jouent beaucoup
kaka datant du livre monkey adjoint vois
quelqu'un gothique servirait qu'à
l'hiver je me dis souvent c'est pour ce
prix que ça vienne me concerne et ouais
ouais pourquoi
bel espoir gothique mais c'est vrai que
si je suis souvent à l'essence que et
piano je me rappelle il s'est approché
de moi puis mesuré je pense y 3 puis
avec cheveux noirs ce que loeb mais
tirait pas de l'air il fallait une moule
n'y avait pas de là il va de la
dangereux il faisait par la cbi de
déchets partout bien
il s'approche il me regarde me faire
jouer saint patrick senécal chef étoilé
oui c'est moi plier fait je m'attendais
vraiment pas à ça plus d'issue bah je
sais pas si jamais tu avais une blonde
et afin d'installer vivent en banlieue
je pense ça se trouvait un couple fait
que oui c'est maladroit mais j'ai pas
n'ont jamais voulu ça j'ai moi ça me
tente pas de jouer une game je joue dans
mes livres dans mes livres je m'amuse
lors le jeu j'ai créé des balades à ma
vraie vie j'ai pas le goût de créer une
image et par goût de créer un patrick
senécal médiatique du goût d'être moi
même puis c'est tout tout ça alors c'est
plus cinq cibles c'est pas acquise à des
bandes pas embarquer là dedans
bon tout ça c'est moi pis moi j'aime pas
ça complique m'a compris et vient
compliquer la vie pour mourir avec
commencé à chercher tout ça à penser à
une image de marque
qu'est-ce que je devrais dire qu'est ce
que devrait alimenter je me trouve bien
chanceux d'avoir du succès maintenant
parce que j'imagine que d'avoir du
succès quelqu'un commence à écrire
aujourd'hui ou qui veut devenir un
acteur ou un chanteur ou une
personnalité dans un milieu quelconque
avec les médias sociaux qui font
entretenir avec toutes les images qu'il
faut cultiver
ça doit être un job épouvantable je
connais des jeunes auteurs ou des jeunes
comédiens qu'entretient des jeunes du
maurice oscille entre eux qui passent
autant de temps sur la médiation entre
entretenir leurs hymnes rock le bok
toujours le hawk parler de moi
pis ils ont pas tu as le choix que ça
ils ont un peu mais en même temps ils
font une ssii s'est pas dit que si je
fais rien si j'entretiens pas ça doit
être une goutte dans l'océan alors moi
j'ai déjà connu pire malgré sa mama mama
webm est parce que je ne connais pas le
web mais ce midi à sécher est en état de
venir faire une petite apparition puis
j'y vois temps en temps mais c'est pas
naturel pente pantone rentrer quand je
le fais je vois différent je vois que le
monde aime son peuple que le monde en
parle mais que je me dis et boy serait
difficile aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui n'a
pas le goût d'entretenir cette image là
quelqu'un comme moi je trouverais ça ta
forme on dit aujourd'hui doit trouver ce
qui donne à voir là des gens qui n'ont
pas le goût de jouer à sommes qu'ils se
rendent compte qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
ils doivent parler de mort et son a reçu
de quelques semaines l'humoriste et
yannick de martino je pense je connais
me disait cet illustre personnage de
st-thomas y est un peu je peux comment
le décrire le mail et/ou disait
justement les réseaux sociaux pour la
santé mentale ammann est ce parce que le
tiff et des toy story le titre chute met
en scène un film à chacun chaque deux
heures mais le second est tout le temps
à ton personnage a mené sa vie
oui les écrivains de morceaux on est
quand même on est privilégié d'un champ
dans dans ce sens que aux personnages
ces pauvres patrons et dirigeants
s'attendent pas dépasser quelqu'un qui
aime un écrivain il s'attend pas à le
voit enfin le clown il s'attend à le
voir en représentation physique guy la
france beaucoup avec 5 leur équipe même
au québec beaucoup moins fait qu on est
quand même moins de pression là dessus
mais ça vient avec le faut aussi qu'un
écrivain est souvent moins connu que
auchan cela est aussi connue mais il
apporte des écrivains ils sont jamais
reconnaît souvent les lignes sont plus
connus que la personne oui c'est ça
c'est très bon comme si c'est mon cas
aussi est bon quand je dis mon nom des
foires à comme l'écrivain
mais carmen du juge pas assez hideux fin
aux notes et entendre quelqu'un me
reconnais que j'aime beaucoup ce que
vous faites des restaurants c'est
sympathique mais le constructeur pense
un peu trop connu un peu trouvé d'être
comprendre bien avec claude legault dans
un bar mettons ce qu'on en fait qu'on a
fait de l'effet mais les syndicats
comptent en promo on sortait temps en
temps il offre ses couettes moi d'être
là ça ramène tournez-vous un peu plus
bob c'est bon ça c'est une bd est c'est
tout et vie est tranquille puis c'est
bien correctement
oui ce qu'est ce que tu crois que c'est
encore possible de tavan un certain
succès sans entretenir une plateforme
web en même temps quelqu'un pour
quelqu'un qui qui débute maintenant et
présentons le comme candidat en bref il
faudrait parce que dans les autres
milieux mimos a me semble compliqué mais
je pouvais pour l'écrivain je pense est
encore possible et je penche pour un
gars comme stéphane larue et stéphane il
ya eu beaucoup de succès son premier
roman mais il sait pas 1 go qui en fait
quelqu'un qui va sur facebook c'est bien
plus pour parler de paix dit qu'elle
allait le barouk est ouvert avec des jo
il va faire avec certains c'est déjà
complet de la passe de trois ans
plongeant aussi des restes europe ce
n'est pas un gars qui valait beaucoup
alimenté son image d'auteur même
quitterait pas là-dessus et il ya quand
même succès mais bon pour la suite des
choses notre falloir qu'ils soient un
peu plus là dedans je ne sais pas
faudrait j en parle d'ailleurs qui ont
intéressante à voir avec lui mais je
pense c'est quand même plus possible
comme comme écrivain mais malgré tout
c'est sûr que j'en vois des jeunes
écrivains qui s'arrange pour aller faire
l'historique c'est comme si je peux
juger ça moi c'est quelque chose que
j'aurais de la misère à faire même si
c'est un groupe qui aime le théâtre mais
je te revois ces shows a recueilli peau
à caboter tout ça mais je le fais
consentante popo
mais j'imagine que ça doit pas nuire
puis temps que ça prend pas en fait
comment je remets ça
il faut pas que quand tu te lèves le
matin qui pense plus à faire sur les
médias sociaux collige que tu es en
train d'écrire ça devient plus
importante parce que tu es plus nerveux
parce que ça fait trois jours que j'ai
pas fait la pression sur facebook que et
satisfera moins nerveux que de dire ça
fait trois jours que j'ai pas écrire mon
livre là je pense que si ce débat lancé
comme ça je pense qu'un problème ton
personnage temps de prendre plus de
place que tonton pourquoi en fait je
fasse le métier là là la vraie raison
pour laquelle on veut faire ce métier
lorsque quelqu'un plus de fun comics en
commun plus de fans à se mettre en
vedette les médias sociaux et de changer
de carrière
on peut avoir du fun paraît il on peut
trouver ça cool moi quand j voie pour
aller sont en fait mon budget qu'on a
fait une coupe de vidéos qu'on explique
qu'en plus il faut en faire un autre jai
pas ça comme une visite un gars qui
quitte à l'aise devant cameron 3,15 à tv
new school puis ce sont les maintenant
il faut être capable avec ce média
menace non là on est vraiment à côté de
la track et des écrivains d'arles qui
sont pas de parler qu'ils ont ça ça sans
modifier le brun aujourd'hui vincent
c'est que là mais faut pas que ça prenne
toute la place
décalage notamment entre le
lèvres puis l'écrivain aussi idiot que
vous êtes c'est ensemble puis passer du
temps ensemble qui sont les gens étaient
surpris de ce duo le probable parce que
au niveau des gens aux antipodes
c'est très drôle parce que les gens ont
encore certaines personnes je peut
généraliser mais certaines personnes ont
tendance encore à associer beaucoup le
l'écrivain et son oeuvre dans ce sens
que c'est écrit comme ça peut-être une
personne comme ça donc
comme j'écris des livres d'or mais chez
quelqu'un de très drôle quand vie et un
dia comme à l'écrit dire à ma jeunesse
ça m'est assez fait beaucoup connaître
au départ pour ça qu'ils sont très
optimistes qui sont et qui sont beaucoup
plus lumineux que limiers qui sont plus
elle le monde parce qu'elle dans la vie
est comme ceux aussi puis c'est vrai qu
est comme ça plus que moi c'est vrai que
c'est une fille qui comme moi je le
mènerai à son 9e oui on sait on équipe
allait vite qu'on écrit pour bien c'est
évident que si j'écris des romans que
j'utilise parce que quelque part d'une
certaine je quelqu'un qui est un peu
pessimiste par rapport à l'espèce
humaine qui ce qui peut être dit oui oui
oui tout à fait c'est ce qu'elle dirait
est plus possible que moi avec mes les
personnes les individus peuvent quand
même se rejoindre là dedans ça fait des
bonnes discussions des fois moi je te
des fois c'est un dieu qui montrent
d'ailleurs patrick des fois il ya du bon
dans vie puis des fois c'est moi qui te
regarde le monde et il retrouve un
équilibre la daps a fait des bonnes
discussions puissent empêche pas que l
des fois tout le monde épouvantable ça
empêche pas que ce capable de voir les
beaux jours mais nous ne sommes pas que
ça faisait des êtres humains se
rejoignent aussi pour d'autres choses
c'est une fille sociale qui aime le
monde moi aussi c'est une fille qui
traiterait vrai je ne fais que papa de
dire ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils mangent
comme ceux aussi qui sont si reconnu là
dessus assez rapidement on aime on est
deux personnes qui m ont le mot qui est
mon frère qui est mauvais et rimade
malgré malgré ce que j'écris donc c'est
comme ma blonde blonde son psychologue
et mégots humaniste moi je pense la
personne n'a plus humaniste que je
connais au monde est quelqu'un qui
trouve qu'à l'être humain vaut toujours
la peine ce quelqu'un voit le meilleur
dans chaque personne si on prend la
thématique de teaser c'est un oui mais
justement est-ce qu'il atterrit chez
nous c'est de ce côté son bloc havrais
commence fait que du manque par semaine
puis moi ce côté lumineux
mind tous les jours je devais cette
fille là pas de ma blonde a fait
quelqu'un de moi de meilleur être humain
je suis sûr que c'est important d'aller
chercher les gens d'autres choses que tu
as tes amis qui te ressemblent pour
gamins d'autres chapitres des amis que
tu ressens moins mais qui t'amène à
autre chose puis je pense que c'est
qu'il est bloqué est important et oui
moi qui obtient des cas qu'on est
ensemble
il ya même des électeurs qui nourrissent
tous les deux non plus drôle que les moi
je dis bah c'est ce projet que vous
lisiez ces deux types de livres aussi
manger quelqu'un qui vous fait signer
d'autres fois le vide je penche pour un
peu plus qu'un ami romain il y avait un
roman de l avait un roman de daniel
desjardins en dessous du bras sur la
partie des quatre dernières desjardins
c'est quand même spécial par le droit
c'est vrai afin que je suis d'électeurs
ligier du genre de roman ben c'est pas
étonnant que ces deux ou trois peuvent
aussi se retrouver
moi j'ai toutes sortes d'amis dans le
milieu littéraire logis et je lis pas
tous mes amis on n'est pas parce que
c'est des zi que tu souhaitais et india
qu'il irait pologne aurait dit la femme
le schiphol
je parlerais non je peux le public
sylviane cédia comprend puisse aimer
correct comme ça et puis j'ai des amis
aussi plaints de ne pas nommer personne
pour pas pour moi je posais les gens que
j pop lit ça que j'ai lu comme et je
faisais ma grosse pour être un chef qui
a déjà que je dis pas parce que je suis
qu'est ce qu'ils écrivent au moins de
toucher mais c'est des gens qui dans la
vraie dans la vie j'ai trouvé
intéressant sympathique pour notre fan
ensemble puis il ya des ces gens là qui
me laisse pas non plus puis c'est bien
correct qui ne font pas il ne faut pas
croire qui me lisent plus que c'est pas
parce que des livres c'est une chose
l'amitié les fréquentations suntono des
fois les deux se rejoignent
des fois c'est deux mondes complètement
séparés
ta femme est pire que ce qu'elle essaie
de comprendre d'où vient ce niveau
ressort le rabatteur des théories de
will et de théorie là-dessus c'est sûr
que comme un mot dit elle ce que les
libéraux début c'est la salade
l'intrigué beaucoup parce qu'elle voyait
bien qu'ils avaient un clash en trois le
leap illégaux parce que c'est depuis
tout jeune en plus que vous êtes
instruit 12 et à me dit c'est sûr que là
la noirceur qui d'environnement c'est
sûr que ça vienne toi écrit quelque
chose qui vient pas de nous à moins
d'être un ghost writer qui écrit pour
d'autres personnes
c'est juste la commande et ça fait
explique pas dans ses livres une
commande justement c'est pas un livre ou
300 tire-larmes de l'écrivain mais
normalement qu'adrien livre c'est pas
une commande d'epo juste préoccupé par
le succès du livre ce que certaines
personnes font en cela dit mais on les
nomme repos mécano mamac normalement 80
m au coeur dans un livre tu parles de
toits par la force des choses même si
par ricochet un mc par métaphore même
c'est pas moi je pense qu'un autre qui
crie sérieusement un roman ou que de
deux planètes qui se font une guerre
intergalactique pense qu'il a tort qui
parle de lui carmen résolution qui parle
exactement fait que des fois mais malgré
toi ça te rends compte dix fois fait que
fait que moi je pense que ma blonde à la
bienvenue sands à à 300 dans tera main
au départ faut que ça vienne de toi donc
arrête pas décrire en faire aussi nous
écrire pour parce que je veux pas que ça
s'accumule comme à 10 à 10 parce que
c'est un jeu dangereux se décrivait pas
mais je serais sûrement quelqu'un de
beaucoup plus déprimé et déprimant plus
pessimiste encore parce que bon je suis
un peu pessimiste mais en même temps
quelqu'un qui aime la vie
quelqu'un que j'ai eu dix enfants de
source parce que je veux bien y croire
c'est plus du cynisme du pessimisme
nommé fin mai donc a dit yves allard
d'évacuation les valeurs de catharsis la
même valeur thérapeutique rire certains
points et c'est dans la vraie vie
justement j'aime tant avoir diffamé
j'aime tant rigoler que je me tiens
caniza desjardins yvon lumineux
c'est ce mât parce que justement cette
noirceur là je la sors d'un
d'environnement et lolo théorique est là
aussi c'est tu parles sûrement départ
dont il rend moins consciemment ou non
elle a l'impression que tu parles de
départ puis l'euro matt donne l'illusion
du contrôle tu racontes tout
l'impression que le temps de remettre
peut contrôler et eu le dessus 7 par la
tuerie ici à parce que parler d'une part
d'une sorte de certains par certains
côtés cesser la contrôler et ici là la
combattre jusqu à certains moments
consciemment je sais quelle raison un
ravin comme contre dieu c'est sûr que ça
parle de pas laissées dios talion aussi
le vide une pas à ce qu'un constat de
certains vite de notre société
c'est aux italiens 16 est venue après la
paternité why wait a minute quand j'ai
eu ma fille il ya eu çà d'un côté et de
l'autre côté il y aussi le fait que je
t'écris voir des films américains qui
montrent que la vengeance est une bonne
idée pour les enfants par semaine en
forme d'amande
puis bon laisser 2 de l'ensemble qu'est
ce que je fais si on faisait mal à ma
fille
et est ce que si si est ce que le mien
si simple que ça c'est à dire que les
anges depuis touba après pillot pas de
problème alors cessé deux ces deux
derniers mois c'est ce que je voulais
c'est de ce que je voulais parler avec
eux donc oui j'ai vécu leur marche
nordique est en soi mais ça parle
consciemment aussi de ma part la motion
qui apparemment
puis je crois qu'il était temps pour un
autre comme moi que plein de monde qui
m'a dans ses livres tout le temps mais
qui a jamais vraiment confrontés la mort
comme la grande finalité
commenge après on se mais je pense que
c'était le temps de deux pilotes soient
encore une fois je me dis peut-être que
si je parle d'un de mes par sa voix
d'une façon de délais avec une façon
d'adopter un peu une façon d'approcher
l'ennemi leurs gardes et des yeux puis
aussi de faire la paix est certain que
jamais la solution j'ai l'impression
d'un coup je peux juger les gens et tout
le monde tout le monde dit l'accès par
qu'un coq comme il veut iliad qui
l'affrontent avec la fille ana qui a fui
nourrissent peu commun jusqu'à quel
point je peux offrir une par lots et
lola octobre oui en fait c'est assez
commun comment tu fais pour vivre avec
il y en a qui trouvent plein de moyens -
manifestement c'est l'écriture dos ça
peut être la lecture on à ce que des
gens qui me lisent peuvent aussi
affronter départ en me lisant à manger
deux côtés seul
pourquoi les gens aiment tant les
sensations fortes pourquoi les gens
aiment les livres parce que c'est aussi
une question comment qu'est ce qu'on
aime d'aller lire dans ces histoires aux
sinois aussi sombre où c'est une
excellente question qu'est-ce qui est ce
qui est une piste de réponse de caisse
qui qu'est ce qui fait qu'un qu'on aime
voir ce qu'est ce qui fait que les films
d'horreur les livres d'horreur les
livres le genre en fait quelque chose
qu'on qu'on recherche activement même si
c'est moi maintenant je regarde un film
d'horreur ça me fait pas me sentir bien
il ya une espèce de quelque chose qu'on
recherche l'on se trouve et beige pas si
j'en cherche pas toutes la même faille à
des gens qui cherchent uniquement le
gros qui cherchent ils aiment voir des
signes très très très sanglantes ça je
pense et le côté puis pau ce sans aucun
jugement de valeur mais le côté kid le
côté enfant spectateurs qui tout énervé
de voir saint qui revoit les effets
spéciaux ayant un gros plat d'un oeil
crevé une cervelle conte aux pires
monstres sont très intéressants
personnellement
mais quand j'étais petit j'aimais ça
c'est le côté immature de l'horreur
qu'on va chercher le cerveau reptilien
équipe de voir ça mais qui implique
aucune émotion parce que que tu devrais
voir quand tu vois quelqu'un faire
ouvrir la page ouvrir le ventre en gros
plan ça devrait être écoeurée suivant
les gens qui aiment ces faits mais
lorsque ça fait ce qu'ils trouvent ça
cool les bras alors on voit que cela on
venait tout premier degré de voir le
plus de 100 possibles c'est pas trés
émotivement implique un mois ce que
j'aime le mieux dans deux à l'horreur au
dal puisque les que certaines personnes
aiment aussi cesser le côté explorer son
côté sombre en fait explorer le côté
sombre de l'être humain peut aller voir
et pourquoi on aime ça ben c'est parce
que et on sait que ça existe
on veut approcher ça m'a proposé dans la
vraie vie c'est dangereux long le fait
de manière sécuritaire et comme la
montagne russe un taux de montagnes
russes
pas par match et que tu arriveras rien
tu sais que normalement la la la la
traque larousse rapport que normalement
il devrait pas continuer tout droit à
dix morts alors lire lire un livre à
sensation faut stopper ça c'est que
wiztivi des émotions fortes celui des
émotions que dans le quotidien suivi pas
normalement
il est suivi par procuration travers un
livre et ça s'appelle j'ai ce côté
ludique le côté thrill c'est ouf
il m'est rien arrivé heureusement ça
s'écoute et montagnes russes mais si
j'ai certaines me romand qu'ils ne sont
que ça que c'est juste une bonne oreille
de montagnes russes mais un ado qui
aussi en même temps qu une ride on
essaye de cette explorer des choses un
peu plus oui au fond de nous un peu plus
notre inconscient à notre côté sombre la
bête en nous qui sommeille pire je pense
qu'on a toutes une bête qui sommeille
n'y a pas d'école surgir jamais pu tant
mieux mais je pense qu on pallie
l'explorer par procuration
et ça donne et ça c'est démontrer c'est
un effet de catharsis la catharsis de
vivre des émotions fortes par
procuration non il le méchant dans nous
et ça c'est comme ça depuis que le monde
est monde veut dire le théâtre grec
servait à seul le terme green dans
l'antiquité ça racontait des histoires
de marc pons étaient moins graphique
évidemment mais pour raconter des
histoires de moeurs d'inceste et ray
pour sortir notre catharsis on allait
voir des rats des 10 j'en fais manger au
cirque de rome la crue des gladiateurs
qui se situait tout ça on eu des
exécutions publiques jusqu'au début du
20e siècle où tu peux aller voir
il dépend des ans la place publique ou
de la guillotine tout ça venez sortir un
tout on tombe mais chacune commence
comme une vidange d'huile en allier
huile quelques projets sur quelqu'un
d'autre
et comme maintenant dans la vraie vie on
efface de plus en plus les traces de
violence de vraies violences et ce qui
est correct aussi mais notre besoin
catharsis et encore la carlingue mais
c'est la fiction qui prend le relais et
pour ça que la fiction est devenue si
violente parce que aux faucons l'évacuer
quelques passes des violences l'appui la
fiction c'est grâce à moi
personnellement si monfils a à choisir
entre un autre gardien jimdo rabbin gore
ou de les voir des gens s'entretuent
dans un arène
oui j'aimerais mieux qu'ils regardent
certains vont dire que justement cette
violence le fasse sortir le méchant
force entre quelque chose puis d'autres
on attendait fois l'argument aussi de
dire que ça va influencer des titres qui
ont été faites la trouvaille est pas
vraiment de débat il monte ses formes un
peu on se rend compte que c'est pas vrai
moi j'ai parlé à cette psychologue dans
ma vie
dans ma blonde puis d'autres ex que
j'écris j'ai eu des tables rondes et des
psychologues
je me rappelle pas d'un psychologue qui
a dit littérature d'horreur littérature
gérante peut être dangereuse me rappelle
pas dit ça sauf s'il ya un encouragement
à n'importe quoi c'est comme il demande
ainsi qu'un crédit dans lequel il dit
écouter prendre un couteau par literie
son voisin ça fait du bien mais c'est le
fun olala c'est un peu quoi comme même
si quelqu'un crise la plupart le commun
des mortels va lire c'est plus va faire
sa part même s'il ya de la violence plus
de ça et mon frère voyons je la vois
contre le code moral comres et l'apport
des gens sont d'accord que te tuer des
gens ce n'est pas une bonne idée
alors si un psy si quelqu'un de normal
lian li viola il va juste éprouver le
dégoût la répulsion ou le plaisir de
catharsis mais c'est qu'un bond en vraie
vie ça pas de sens est un psychopathe
qui voit les sommes payées déjà parce
qu'à part livrade repos vous au lit vos
potes donné des idées
il ya eu oui je sais que par exemple la
campagne q la tuerie les deux jeunes qui
ont été tués un playon suivent 12
personnes dans leur école on a découvert
dans l'île que la semaine d'avant il y
avait coûté le film de matrix une
douzaine de fois qu'ils sont rentrés
dans l'école y avait des longs cours de
qi comme dans matrix
çà et là on me dit ah ça y est on a des
responsables c'est la faute
mais combien de personnes ont vu de
matrix dans la nuit vingt personnes
ayant kahn a convié là dessus qu'ils ont
construite non la cause 2 est concentré
dessus que ça va péter morén manson ou
de maturer qui s'arrêtait autre chose
des ces gens là étaient perturbés
maniéré pu voir n'importe quel truc ça
leur donner une idée il ya un petit gain
de 8 ans qui se promène est sorti le 1er
mai 2009 lui qui plaide effets spéciaux
pas bon le métier de rôle pareil ce que
dit à la mi septembre à bord est mort
est ce que quelqu'un à cause de ça pour
prétendre que les femmes se promènent
est un film dangereux réserve
par quel état et est enfin là au départ
commence à ceux qui n'ont pas compris à
8 ans qu'est ce que tu as beau toutefois
sa maison aussi premièrement etc et il
ya plein de questions comme ça alors le
livre le une oeuvre d'art ne rend pas
quelqu'un ne transforme pas quelqu'un en
ce qui n'est pas on veut prétendre le
sol parce qu'on aimerait bien savoir
qu'une oeuvre d'art change le monde
moi j'étais un peu sceptique là dessus
lors s'adresse seulement aux gens qui
sont déjà convaincus de ce que tu veux
dire c'est quand ça va moins je pense
que oui malheureusement je pense ça peut
aider du monde qui sont en
questionnement cela peut amener des gens
se poser des questions mais je dis je
pense pas que je pense pas que quelqu'un
qui suit le point de tuer l'assassin de
sa fille volé mon livre enfin dans ce
pont de bondy finalement mais je pense
que c'est mais je pense que oui cette
année des réflexions savané des
discussions prédictions ceux qui parmi
les gens changent et par un impact comme
ceux au met et 6 il a transformé le
monde à ce point là je dis depuis le
début du times urbain plus d'amour
quatre films d'horreur le monde s'aime
pas vraiment mieux c'est ça alors si si
mes livres doha et français les gens à
devenir mes chats mais pourquoi les
films d'amour et france pas les gens à
devenir amoureux ses parts de marché
juste d'un bord et que moi là j'ai fait
la paix avec ça l'idée que je peux
donner des idées aux gens je pense que
dd maniaque peuvent me lire mais c'est
pas moi qu'ils rendent une manière
excessive ces bonnes idées que je
défends non plus je pense non mais t'as
raison c'est quelque chose qu'on me
demande souvent que vous avez raison
mais est-ce que néanmoins ça vous est
arrivé que l'interprétation d'un lecteur
mais tant que vous rencontrez au salon
du livre n'importe où
puis la conclusion qui sert de nouveaux
heurts ce soit paul votre attention
métier mais tombe et on comprend
justement je reprends l'exemple du
roadster volonté que tu disais tantôt
que c'était pas à glorifier pas la
vengeance qu'ils le but du livre c'est
peu de dire fonctionnement se venger
landry comme ce mes
et peut-être que c'est déjà lui qui
arrive dix mots je le comprends qu'il ya
bien fait j'aurais fait pareil je crois
mais en fait c'est sa meilleure nuance
est donc intéressante c'est que et déjà
qu'elle me voir et me disent c'est juste
un exemple parfait pour il ya des gens
qui viennent me voir qui me disent
rajoutons ramaz puis au début c'est
d'accord avec la part des familles puis
là je savais plus trop maintenant c'est
une bonne idée ou pas devant le christ a
fait réfléchir
moi ce que je veux que le monde
réfléchit se pose la question mais
avantage conscient que je peut pas
diriger bon puis donc à des gens aussi
qu'elle me voir et me disent
moi je comprends que tout voulu dire là
mais moi je leur ai tout est pareil et
ça c'est correct aussi dans ce sens que
ont compris ce que je voulais faire
passer sa télé les gens peuvent
comprendre l'époque d'accord il s'assied
privilège du lac c'est le privilège du
du lecteur parce que je pète un
moralisateur non plus je veux pas dire
ceux qui sont pas d'accord vous êtes des
écoles devaient rien compris c'est
gérard olive beaucoup plus d'icônes
dichotomique que ça vient faire quelque
chose qu'avec beaucoup plus polarisant
pas polarisé mais beaucoup plus changé
en dix ans n'aurait bleus écouter ceux
qui sont contre l'avant succès pour la
vengeance des écureuils de toute l'ue
qui avait rien gobry ceux qui ceux qui
sont pour la vengeance jeudi et ceux qui
sont comblés vous avez tout compris
moi je lui ai montré que le père de
famille
il pose la question puis finit par faire
le choix de ne pas le faire mais parce
que j'ai faim que tu compris parce que
cette hargne de le tuer par en dedans
j'ai montré que c'est un risque qui
arrive mais je n'ai pas montré
complètement que ce soit pas d'accord
avec ce oui c'est ça réfléchissez à ça
et que moi que des gens disent je
comprends ce que tu veux faire mais je
pas d'accord correct parce que mon
jaillit un film qui me dit libon saison
ils sont récompensés les méchants qui
sont punis
c'est trop simple mais c'est trop simple
mais en même temps tu as toujours une
opinion comme on tente à toujours moins
mal à l'aise là
l'objectivité absolue objectivité
absolue j'y crois pas écrit un livre de
quand même une intention tout avec mais
par contre j'avais quinze jours du
talion en dix ans il s'est vengé puis a
bien fait puis on devait te venger
quelqu'un est venu boire il dit car en
études montrent que le monde se mange ta
raison un sam un cadre et bleu bras
dessus mais qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec moi je sais c'est correct et les
lecteurs à la liberté ou si de croire ce
qu'ils veulent c'est ça c'est ces mots
j'ai toujours pensé cela minutes
quelques élèves quittaient l'auteur elle
appartenait plus est la partenaire à
personne qui ce qu'il voit et se la
procurer oui souvent souvent on essaie
de envoie des des créateurs pas
nécessairement littérature mais aussi en
cinéma qui font des entrevues vraiment
longue et extensive sur qu'est ce qu'ils
ont voulu dire dans les duels étaient le
chemin emprunté puis j'ai trouvé que
c'était là la façon d'aborder l'ordre en
général d'accord moi je pense qu'il faut
laisser là on peut dire ce qu'on voulait
faire un peu gaffe chine de faire des
choses et à lyon mais un site donne un
guide d'emploi avec chacun de tes vie où
chacun des films le sadi un peu un
problème parce qu'il me semble que le
sens que le spectateur le lecteur peut
peut d'ailleurs il ya un radiateur
michael hanecke équipe qui refuse
toujours de
d'expliquer cfm toujours toujours ça
c'est un peu frustrant parce que des
fois j'aimerais qu'ils aient caché lâché
en fait caché à fait à mon fait un film
le ruban blanc
urbas bla il fait un film terrible des
films les plus horribles que je doive
ticket qui était il ya fait une version
américaine mais sap la première version
série sont l'autrichien qui est un film
terrible terrible pilage acheter un
livre d'entretiens avec lui leurs
cabanes énervé j'ai commencé à lire un
peu moins oui il du commun qui
travaillent parle des thèmes devait
aborder mais autour une mangue oui mais
dans ton faible aucun cas tel syndicat
qui était lui-même sommes des scènes
flou le spectacle qu'est ce tu le dis
ils refusent systématiquement réponde à
ça c'est correct même si carey goût et
on aimerait bien savoir des fois mais
dit il ya une confiance
ap absolue à l'intelligence du
spectateur exemple il veut que louis
jeune intentions mais en même temps dans
vraie vie on assiste à des trucs des
fois le même sens que mon vol est
apprêté différemment betty top ça que je
veux faire
évidemment que yo mais ça et en
intention dans le film ci a pas
d'intention c'est plate mais non il y
aura pas de mode d'emploi précis pour
chaque pour chaque commande afin de
cacher justement le fils deux jeunes qui
vont se parler à l'école du personnage
important
on les voit de loin se parle le film
fini comme çà on n'arrête pas de
demander qu'est ce qu'ils disent qu'est
ce qu'ils sont en train de se dire est
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire la paix
qu ce qui s'est passé le jeu pour 3 et
parce que ce gars mobile m1 ou et son
panier de démons mon écart en jambes en
gs que puis année qui répond
que vous voulez puis j'aimerais savoir
qu'est ce qu'ils doivent aux acteurs ils
leur disent elles à faire ce que vous
voulez je sais pas gbb spécial ce
mystère qui entoure son oeuvre
ils sont super forts de trois jours
destinée qu breake moderne que chaque
oeuvre est différent par formule de
kubrick mais pas trop non plus parler de
cfm pas parler de ses films non plus
parler de fin de match qui a été la fin
la plus énigmatique du cinéma séparément
à fin 2011 a vécu là encore c'était la
pluie mais moi j'aimerais connaître
prestations pour moi 2001 c'est madame
qui raconte dix ans je suis curieux
comble chez l'homme ces passionnés
latence et si tu rends compte que c'est
l'homme qui rencontre dieu moi je pense
que c'est mme là c'est l'être humain qui
rencontre son créateur je pense que là
la stalle vous m'avez des monolithes moi
c'est un c'est la création absolue ccc
dieu dieu comme on est
c'est pour ça que c'est un carré noir
parce qu'un dieu on voit comme on veut
dire on le voit soit comme le vieux
barbu qui brosse une image qui moi me
plaît pas du tout où on voit jouer comme
une espèce de force sans penser sans
volonté mais qui est une force créative
absolue de l'univers qui ces notes c'est
noir c'est profond ce que de perdre
là-dedans et à la fin le personnage qui
rentre dans la stage puis lyon il
devient de fait tout ce qui flotte à
côté de la terre parce que kaka
trinquons dieu
pour satan du loft un symbole mais il ya
plus de tailler plus d'espacé plus de
biais le total et moi je pense plus qu'à
la fin il vieillit rajeuni bon il voit
toutes les étapes à toutes les nuits est
possible à être de cette vie alors on
tombe dans la grosse philosophie là mais
je pense qu'il faut pas leur en demander
son cherchent un sens plus précis plus
matérielles que sache pas ce qu on fait
fausse route lors c'est là où il se rend
con qui raconte dieu mais qui se raconte
lui même l'homme qui trouve le sens de
la vie mais qui ne peut pas nous être
révélée parce que ça draine ou même
rentrer dans un monologue pour le grand
chose à lire extra un film
extraordinaire
ce n'est pas un film facile dans le sens
qu'il est très très long des passages
dans l'espace même extrêmement
contemplatif une oeuvre d'art autant
regarder cac pourrait être regardé saber
al aqsa son salon puisse laisser porter
on le voit sur un écran géant
ouah ça c'est un écran dans une autre
absurde compliqué tout ça chez nous les
amazighs qui est maniaque de cinéma fait
que peut s'arranger pour voir mes films
dans des conditions optimales pour le
son avec le selor prades sans cela leur
prend dix ans qu'un kit envahissant
parce que tous deux se rencontrent là
dedans coque comme les personnages
rentrer là dedans aussi c'est l'espace
et l'infini c'est bon et que oui mais
c'est pas un film peut pas opposer
bourgoin dessus de 1000 ans avant
d'aller prendre une bien c'est pas ça
aulas et par fabien cela porte un nom la
séquence de
le voyage que l'on s'est un peu lent
dans un cinéma mais en 1970 c'était
peut-être une bonne idée
aujourd'hui ce passage là j'avoue que je
le passe quand je le regarde tous très
calme que celle là c'est vraiment
ridicule fois jeudi alors que tous les
autres passages dans l'espace quand ça
prend son temps à la musique ça ça me
dérange pas je suis comme l'a abandonné
à cette ambiance là mais le patient
psychédélique leur ont dit qu'ils
découvraient les lignes joseph est
tellement révolutionné la science
fiction parce qu'avant c'était star trek
ou cet été c'était oui c'était il ya
deux ans dans les spas aux marques
conférence oil & frémont raccordement je
pense est le seul film de science
fiction au monde rarement le plus
réaliste doit d'avoir un autre qui oui
c'est sûr qui dit que dans l'espace en
tout voilà un timbre c'est tellement les
effets spéciaux ont montré que c'était
hallucinant commencé il ya plus une fois
que tu vois 2001 pictet cie mais le fait
mais maintenant je le vois deux fois le
prix comprend les mécaniques injuste
elle pas juste l'histoire mais tu
comprends les mécaniques et
cinématographique du fait mieux qu un
film de science fiction que poppy j'ai
quelque chose dans la magie n'est
intéressé cette installation ouaki oui
il ya un hommage à illies a faite c'est
d'avoir la même femme de science fiction
aussi par la science fiction c'est un
autre genre que je suis pas j'entends
ces femmes que ça parce que
parce que c'est mon réveil sonne
science fiction c'est difficile de la
section aller puis les hauteurs de
tension c'est sont toujours un peu déçu
et surpris que les gens en lisent pas
tant que ça mais c'est pas étonnant
parce que il faut que non seulement tu
découvres une histoire il se découvre un
monde découvre montée je parle pas de
science fiction - section qui se passe
des voyages intergalactiques c'est moins
paix parce que c'est quand même assez
près notre réalité actuelle
1 l'ascension invente donc l'aneth
d'autres mondes d'autres civilisations
ou même sur la terre mais dans 2000 ans
au compteur
c'est beaucoup de stock à assimiler pour
quelqu'un qui veut comprendre des
émotions personnage la psychologie il
est là et beaucoup de science fiction
pas toutes là avant que mes amis qui la
conditionne à votre demande l'envoi des
emails ou je sais pas quoi
il ya de la science-fiction bas
l'horreur aussi remarquer ce que je dis
là s'applique à l'arer aussi mais plus
la science fiction
les brodeurs d'ascension qui prennent
tellement de temps c'est des cerveaux en
ce qu'ils écrivent ces des cerveaux ses
cerfs-volants souvent s'intéresse
beaucoup à la construction de leur monde
à tout le côté comment dire très précis
de la mécanique de ce côté technique web
et le côté aussi très philosophique des
questionnements mais souvent très
froidement très froidement avec des
personnages qui ont pas beaucoup de vies
ont pour beaucoup d'émotion qui ont pas
beaucoup d'un sidekick qui sont justes
dans le fond des des archétypes de la
pensée de l'auteur mais qui ont peu de
crédibilité comme individus pensent en
aimant avec de deschacht est d'assez bon
ça fait souvent dans les mauvais cause
dans les cas sociaux moins intéressante
ça fait dix romans très froid et à simav
c'était un génie l'association mais ces
faits à tabarre nos chambres
c'est vraiment fait la queue avec l'état
les gens ont voulu de l'ascension qui
ont aussi de la chair et du sang et de
la sueur et des de bon il y en a qui lui
réussissent très bien cela dit des
auteurs des inscriptions qui réussissent
à mes années qu'ils réussissent moins
bien puis je pense que c'est l'autre les
gens ont peu plus de difficultés car
quand quand ça donne des cas comme ça
les fourmis par exemple les fourmis
s'éteint c'est un cas spécial manger les
fonds mis ses d'ascension les fourmis sa
part du monde des humains et le monde
des fourmis convenait pas se rencontrer
mais pendant les deux tiers du roman
ces fourmis
famille est très curieusement on est
plus près des fourmis on croit plus aux
personnalités des fourmis que tous les
chapitres parle des humains ou là ça
marche pas qui croit juste pas si c'est
ça être là les humains donc l'auteur a
plus discuter a dit l'église mains
qu'avec les fourmis passé assez curieuse
et en inde
une décision de faire porter des humains
de manière objective de loi qui veut
leur donner des émotions aux mains de
fois qu'il veut leur faire faire des
trucs tout ça mais c'est invraisemblable
10-3 peau de tout ce qu'ils font n'est
né à ce que pour moi n'était pas
crédible mais à chaque fois qu'on venait
des fourmis l'on y croyait au beau trop
beau trop beau double et que c'est un
peu pour moi un espèce de stéréotypes de
science fiction quand ça marche pour moi
c'est quand même bon les fourmis par
l'émotion les partenaires mais j'aimais
ça l'est parce que le côté des
difformités tellement fascinant quand je
peux si crème voilà justement un exemple
d'un auteur de science-fiction qui
connaît plus la science qui me connaît
plus les bibittes connaît plus les lie
les questions fusent fait que l'humain
dans son quotidien est il humain dans la
vie de tous les jours et ça chauffe ça
c'est fascinant mais des rames
association qui réussissent et moins des
meilleures notations j'écris ces
derniers certains québécois que les
écrits qui s'appelle cranach aig est
rarement sa session extraordinaire
et là c'est très émouvant aussi le le
côté humain émotions marche en même
temps que le côté pour les riches à
petit maintenant qu'ils aient manqué
quelques années était un auteur de
science-fiction qui réussissent à les
moyens alors je dis pas que c'est mon
possible mais cela c'est une terra tueur
qui s'occupe trop de la science et de la
technologie et de ce cri un monde et
moins de l'humain et laura rossi là je
je je je je parle à ceux qui pensent que
les cartes de gens en général à ce
risque là c'est à dire des plus
préoccupés par les codes et d'être
occupé par ses personnages et l'émotion
qui doit venir avec les mauvais films
d'art en cd rom injustement tout le
monde ment mais tout le monde s'en fout
que tout bonnement parce qu'on n'est pas
tâche n'est pas attaché ces personnages
là il nous intéresse pas dont une est
dimensionné elles sont alors ça ça veut
dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui marche
pas là alors c'est aussi ça se peut dans
la rolls
le code le genre qui l'emportent sur les
personnages et sur l'émotion qui doit
s'en dégager j'ai au cégep un cours avec
gilles pellerin est un écrivain
québécois puis lui qu'un qui parlait de
science fiction et disait à son avis le
meilleur auteur de science-fiction
c'était jules verne
parce que lui dans jules verne qui
écrivait ses livres lui va mieux je suis
moi aussi un sous marin comme ça
n'existait pas c'est un de quoi de
fabuler par jules verne depuis le roman
s'attache justement au personnage
il ya quelque chose de surnaturel d'un
danseur est quelque chose de science
fiction inception plus tôt exact ouais
sauf que sauf que leurs mains et tourne
pas autour de ceux-ci et le sous marin
c'est une des choses dans ces lieux ouah
mais qui offre pour figer l'on pourrait
avoir une bonne ce qu'ils ont là dessus
mais moi je je trouve que je trouve que
dans un roman de 800 pages tort 200
pages du roman puis 600 pages de
descriptions de poissons de d'algues
comme un grossissement parce quelqu'un
qui s'intéresse aux côtés sciences de
science fiction le côté visionnaire
extraordinaire par une audi qui est pas
bon là je parle de plaisir personnel à
le lit mais je comprends qu'elle ait pas
qu'on le lui on ne te faire ta et aussi
la télévision n'existait pas alors lui
kaka quand on était en dessous de l'eau
avec lui qui décrit tous les poissons
convoi travail le blue pendant des pages
et des pages de l'état qui sautent
découvre 19h que jamais vu exactement
exactement
aujourd'hui j'ai pas besoin d'être seul
je vais aller à écouter une arche est
géographique liu tout moment voir des
poissons mais j'allais voir la lune
cascades là je suis allé moi mais je
vienne il offrait au monde une vision
des choses que les gens n'avaient pas
les j'avais pas accès à seraing et je
peux comprendre qu'à l'époque c'était
pour sa part wister g à sa section au
même mois aujourd'hui lire jules verne
tout ce côté documentaire la m'ennuie
profondément puisque les personnages moi
parce que j'ai lu de jules verne les
personnages sont assez inédit
mentionnait chou qui sont plus
fonctionnels et y servent ils servent à
n'aller pas que ccst la télévision de
l'époque
le cinéma de l'époque c'était le choix
des recherches hallucinante
tenez le mystérieux c'est moi qui
décrivent pendant 300 pages commun qui
construisent leur maison commun qui sont
à manger puis commun qui construisent la
gueule comme un trousseau de l'ennui
épouvantable c'est pas intégré dans
l'histoire à l'époque ce côté
documentaire là est important et
d'ailleurs tous les auteurs du 9ème
siècle faisait seul crime est beaucoup
beaucoup parce c'est pas le seul
faisaient partie de deux bien plus donc
il faisait ça et en plus ya menace des
histoires imaginatives
alors oui je peux comprendre mais pas qu
est écrit comme je le vern aujourd'hui
ça serait un peu absurde soit peu
absurde et moi le livre aujourd'hui ça
moi personnellement ça m'ennuie mais il
ya plein de gens qui a dans ses
descriptions là pendant des pages des
pages très personnelle à ce niveau là
mais si on prend maintenant parce
qu'effectivement écrire comme ça est un
peu désuet maintenant par contre il ya
quand même des prestations si on garde
le plongeur qu'on parlait tout à l'heure
à fleury les scènes bien les résines
sont d'ex de rangement descriptive son
cd longue des longues périodes sauf que
on dirait que l on a le temps il a
réussi à le faire de façon qui équilibre
auquel il faut que ce soit clair les
assiettes c'est un portable dans leur
racheter dans la roche en même temps qu
il à ces six mois je dis pas que les
descriptions sont faits plus décrié
aujourd'hui c'est pas ce jeudi l'appui -
le dix neuvième siècle en passant je
suis un fan je suis un gros fan c'est
moi j'étais fan de hall of fame et
descriptions biologique par la plante en
sarre approche naturaliste
tout à fait et puis en fait j'ai fait un
roman qui vous raconte je parle de la
flamme de la foi de la rue fait un roman
qui va à contre courant de ce qui se
fait maintenant au québec c'est à dire à
part dans les romans de genre moi j'en
fais des prix de 500 pages mais les
auteurs sérieux je n'ai eu de guillemets
en général ces 250 morts 150 pages 200
pages c'est de l'auto fiction ça parle
de ces bébêtes personnel le tout fiction
dans le livre de stéphane meyer vraie
histoire aux cibles est encore là
attention je ne dis pas que tous les
auteurs québécois font je sors mes yeux
une tendance à ça il ya un gros disque
là
la danse dans des tendances dans
l'oreille des tendances dans la
littérature sérieux il ya toujours des
tendances dans toute littérature dans la
mienne aussi le juge que ce soit clair
stéphanie tard avec un roman un gros
roman oui avec l'auto fiction mais avec
une vraie coupe dramatique avec la
description très 19e siècle thomas écrit
à l'américaine c'est vraiment écrit
l'américaine il s'est passé pas défaut
au contraire moi quand j'ai écrit à
l'américaine ça veut dire un souci de
l'efficacité tout le temps d'épuiser à
la grappe et je suis très réaliste puis
puis même cédé longs passages qui se
passe pas grand chose c'est plus dans
l'ambiance de restaurants c'est toujours
est il toujours à la recherche de
joueurs un seul plus efficace possible
ce qui était le cas dans certains
romanciers 19e siècle il ya un autre -
balzac s'était pas toujours l'efficacité
balzac c'est la discrétion la discussion
pour ça des fois ça m'ennuyait pour
rappeler aussi qu'ils étaient chrome os
ces gens là là c'est pas très noble com
com comme les pauses universel 10 - mais
il était écrit au mot il était payé au
monde avec un plus haut à 100 m 2e
siècle que ce malheur livre surtout dans
les journaux sortait dans les stades
différents alors oui ils étaient payés
aux mots ok sauf canada que
l'intelligence de dire tant qu'à faire
beaucoup de mots - inventer quelque
chose puis balzac qu'on aime qu'on les
aime pas c'est un des premiers écrivains
qui décrit la led à pascal ont dû
trouver la beauté mais lieu dit les
choses laides les choses du peuple les
choses qui sont normalement pas
artistiques mérite d'être décrite mérite
d'être sauvé ne serait ce que pour ça
chapeau mais donc oui c'est je crois
qu'on peut plus écrire de cette manière
là mais si on écrit que des descriptions
il faut moderniser sont quand même bien
quand ça pourrait avoir l'impression de
déjà décrit pendant dix pages une scène
de restaurant uniquement pour montrer la
différence avec la rue c'est que quand
tu décris ces cinq de rage en restera le
but n'est pas de dire voici comment
fonctionne un restaurant du un peu de ça
mais le vrai but c'est de dire checker
comme un conte roche asti regardé comme
apprenti dans ce but par ouvrir des
questions qu'est-ce qui ressent en
faisant un saut puis heath et ils sont
prévues dès que ça marche a répète
emmerdante à barnes noble * oui moi moi
moi quand on me dit que beaucoup d'un
sign et restera
des cris de rage pendant dix pages j'ai
fait comme un coeur que c'est ça donc
mon l'essayer parce que tout le monde en
parle mais cool moi j'allais prendre ma
douche après 5 d'harrachov tu aimes
aussi puis c'est un tour de force dont
quand même donc c'est encore possible de
faire ça mais c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile
moi j'ai au moment où est-ce que c'est
sorti j'avais un j'avais un séminaire de
maîtrise sur la littérature actuelle
puis quand c'est sorti comme notre
session ont tourné autour de ce
tellement c est un gros gros bang des
majors et un groupe inspiré stéphane qui
est un gars très intelligent icompta de
ce buzz lameilhé peu fou il dit l'oeil
est tellement grosses baskets jyloge je
sais que j'ai l'impression le deuxième
va mal il pas de dire à mon deuxième
roman avoir marché spot à quoi il fait
nouveau il y ait des groupes demandent
déjà si y en a que des gros base puis
qu'après ça s'arrête beau monde s'est
embêté parce qu'elle dit parce qu'on
sait jamais ce qui peut arriver parce
que toi il ya eu la sagesse
l'intelligence et la modestie aussi de
dire on verra deuxième et parce qu'ils
pensent comme ça ça va sûrement l'aider
pour le 2ème probablement le premier
pour équipe
un écrivain ne doit jamais rien prendre
pour acquis rona il prend son temps ça
oui
en même temps il ya de l'urgence des
fois il est urgent surfer sur le buzz
ouais en ont mais je parle pas de surgir
de l'urgence quand il écrit moi qui me
rappelle quand j'avais lu le plongeur on
allait prendre une bière après on était
rentrés en contact contes et légendes et
puis voilà je disais je me défoule je
pose la question moi j'ai l'impression
qui écrit ce roman là quand même assez
vite parce que tu vas y avait quelque
chose dire que dans ce roman puis ben
oui j'ai écrit j ai pensé à couver l'on
taille mais il ya un an à un moment
donné des pages que j'écrivais cette
urgence là c'est pas parce que tu écris
un roman dans l'urgence et tu décris
vite que pas été pensé pendant longtemps
avant cela dit que donc oui il prétend
l'urgent me prend son temps dans ce sens
que qu'à son deuxième roman il pourrait
dire le respect là dessus puisque dans
la zone a fait quoi 12 ans qui sortent
ils se sentent non peas et qui est
attendue fête qui veut corps justement
il y avait des gens de dire je publie
chez n'importe quoi parce qu'elle
nourrit le volvo veut être à la hauteur
à la hauteur de lui-même en fait une
demande en divorce d'entrevue que c'est
avait pris 5 6 ans écrire 51,50 que des
hommes qui trois mois écrit le deuxième
oui au sucre au drame bonne idée
mais oui c'est parce que j'avais jeté à
l'université de damas temps partiel
puisque je voulais l'emmener chez des
éditeurs celui là sa première fois gens
voyagent écrivain de romans avant mais
qui sont dans mon garde-robe la première
fois que je voulait l'envoyer chez un
éditeur fait que kb nerveux je
travaillais tout renvoyer puis ça a
marché trois fois que vous jugiez ce que
tu fais ça c'est bon pour dray oui c'est
havage j'y pense c'est pour moi
j'écrivais pour le fun j'écrivais parce
que mecha me lisez pas ce que jamais
écrire tamani le monde même si bête
peut-être essai publié cet âge me suis
dit là je me suis pris pour un autre
comme ça arrive souvent 4,17 un pic que
tout commence à écrire ou à jouer de la
musique ou la fai participent à tout le
monde mais il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
quittent d'accous pense en train
d'inventer quelque chose personne comme
si je pouvais d'être inspiré par
personne parce que j'avais en parle
parce que j'ai enseigné longtemps j'ai
vu des jeunes de même mais c'est cute un
cépage parfum de diction tp qui sont au
dessus sont ils canalisent malheur
enthousiasme ans à la nati voler la
trace ceux qui ont vraiment du talent
savoir placer ce que c'est juste deux
moines c'est un jeu marine qu'elle avait
un certain talent pour faire ce que je
fais maintenant aujourd'hui mes 17 ans
je pensais pas que je m'en sorte un
tannage part
cast aip -le est à la pensée que tel est
le plus apte le germaniste pas à force
d'être choisi par téléphone que tu es
bon porter preuve que tu es bon mot est
faible qu'il doit être bon en maudit
pour vrai mais ces cages arrêter de
penser de même que ça a marché mais
calme du calme me disais ça j'ai écrit
un manuscrit que j'ai envoyé un éditeur
dans un concours littéraire concours
majeur du québec la régie écoutez moi je
pense qu'on lui dit pavillon
j'avais même peur travail et j'avais
même peur fait j'ai envoyé un premier
jet qu'ont vécu d'être écartée comme
écouter at ça marche pour titre c'est un
concours dédié à des livres de jean
mêmes peuvent même pas gagné j'étais sûr
que j'allais gagner
il devint non seulement j'ai pas gagné
mais j'ai jamais eu jamais eu de réponse
n'est jamais rien eu
j'ai porté une intro premier comme je
dis non ils ont même pas fainéant et là
j'étais frustré que j'ai braillé de rage
pendant trois jours en zinc ndt vous
avez rien compris à m'amener à force de
brailler pas force de janzé ammonites
fait une petite voix dans toi qui fais
ya peut-être une nation apprentis q2 il
là je lis ma leçon c
quant aux nerfs travail tes textes
imposent d'université en même temps
presse une coupe d'un après midi loto du
talent mais tu travailles pas le foot ce
travail parce que ce serait publiée un
jour vos frocs travail et ex là on voit
le talent mais on voit pas le travail
puis moscou et en tabarnouche et si
l'objet 55 hockey lah la joie vraiment
travailler j'en fais plusieurs j'ai
alors commencé jeudi
j'ai tout fait ça ça marche et notamment
énervé de publier un premier roman
qu'elle creuse yvan publié non mais je
pense un pad encore cinq ans que j'avais
pour moi les créer mais je les ai pensé
pendant six mois avant mais le six-fours
trouver une idée il faut je trouve qu
que j'en écrive un vite il faut que ce
soit donc une idée assez simple pour
beaucoup de personnages pour beaucoup de
dieu un punch la donne et le passager et
le passager même si je laime beau j'aime
bien c'est quand même de tous mes romans
s'il fallait qu'on en brûle 1/2 roma
serait lui choisir un seul à pleurer en
pleurant et en même temps c'est
paradoxal c'est ma porte d'entrée dans
l'est dans les écoles secondaires des
six rameurs qui fait que beaucoup
beaucoup de profs les mettre au
programme avec un secondaire donc serait
brûlé ma carte de visite mais
artistiquement parlant
c'est mon roman le moins ambitieux car
même celui qui repose sur une gamme iq
un punch est même possible nouveau comme
punch et bien failli et efficace je
comprends pourquoi qui lui des écoles
secondaires y ait pas long mais moi
comme créateur c'est pas un roman qui
qui qui qui qui qui commandait le pont
roman dans lequel j'ai montré de ce qui
ce dont je suis le plus capable côté
créatif vanille pour rien renier leur
puis ça fait partie des évolutions de ce
que de ce que je suis est ce que dans ce
3 mois l'on compte la réécriture parce
que c'est souvent seul le nerf de la
guerre dans un nom trois mois je
l'envoyer chez les stars ok pour quatre
mois j'ai envoyé une star pas vraiment
pris deux mois quatre mois où il faut
que tu l'envoies c'est qu'ils
terminaient ou payant quand ce travail à
savoir à manchester face à djabou aussi
un bon histoire fait sa job c'est à dire
que yves ollivaud lépi votre deck youth
singe pas serein et nantais la falla un
plaid sur travail avec ce kit que tu es
d'accord ou non avec lui parce que mon
histoire aux accepté évidemment si vous
entendez pas parentaux de beloeil il
publie repas en général je trouve un
équilibre puis moi je la fais lire aussi
en coupe de mes amis pentagone histoire
en qui j'ai beaucoup confiance qu'ils
vont faire une bonne job et que moi j'ai
des avis même aujourd'hui maintenant moi
j'ai quatre hectares le gérant manger
quatre lecteurs depuis tête de rat
marché dirrell 7,3 que dans des colonies
depuis douze romans olivier sabino
reniflage mon charme ni olivier sabino
lucide assaf au moins cinq romans qui
lit ma blonde et à mon histoire c4
personnelle ils lisent en même temps non
pas vrai ma blonde est liée en premier
après ça je suis dit comment je fais des
ajustements selon ce qu'à me dit elle le
lit pose lui il y en a plusieurs jours
la joie joie jours je vois ces réactions
joue assez et après ça le ajustements il
a j'envoie mes deux chats mais mon
histoire en même temps les commentaires
et je suis libre d'accepter ce que je
joue ou non mais je dirais que ce soit
15 % de ce qui me dit je suis d'accord
ces gens là j'ai confiance en eux depuis
des années pour pourriez ils se trouvent
sur marque en plus des points communs
exactement exactement kkk l'i3 les
quatre méthodes ma blonde le dit aussi
mais serait ce qu'un petit avance quand
je dois quand je corrige suite
si les trois autres après ce commentaire
c'est sinon on n'y croit pas les trois
disent oh tu peux toujours débat moi je
pense qu'à marche mais ne te fais
attention le jan trouve intelligent qui
depuis des années un kit est confiant il
y 3 sans se consulter disent que cette
scène là je comprends pas l aspect où
j'y crois pas moi je pense fauteils
l'humilité de lyon raison et il leur
travail soit rené un moment ram enfin
quelqu un spectacle de cirque là dedans
il ya un cirque qui fait un spectacle
complètement déjanté très trash qui met
les gens mal à l'aise qui déboule dans
son spectacle sont belles et branly
prend le spectre 7 pour adultes le j'ai
monté un show complet là pendant dix
pages explique 1 1 1
un show de cirque et plus que je pense
en tabarnouche le pl us toute logique de
ce show de circa j'ai travaillé là
dessus il lâché lire sans harnais il à
mon éditeur le lire libé lippi rooney
mais d'un 3e juste rallye qui dit c'est
sa tronche aux tons chauds tâche paraît
inégal tons chauds trash c'est ça dis
moi je m'excuse midi s'il faut voir ce
show là où je veux être un peu ébranlé
mais pas tant que la is patrick aux
foufounes électriques des planches de
bois que tu peux faire quelque chose de
plus perturbant que leur travail mais je
me dis bien raison mais si je peux n'ont
pu ramener que le monde se sauve en
croit il dit non mais tu peux faire
quelque chose d'un peu plus
j'ai commencé mon j'ai gardé la même pas
mais j'ai fait des numéros un peu plus
élevé un peu plus
il ay là il lui a fait droit et cela ça
marche le loge de reconnaît que c'est
des fois c'est confronte un mais là tu
oblige à aller plus loin et ça t'oblige
à sortir le mieux de toi ça te passent
commande il ya des choses que tu vois
plus tu vois plus loin - l'écrivain qui
vit aujourd'hui un écrivain que ça fait
et je pense que c'est le cas de beaucoup
d'écrivains qui ont beaucoup de succès
et stephen king et tout ça je pense que
c'est des gens manic qui on leur laisse
pubis et ont pu de travail d'édition ils
en ont beaucoup moins sous prétexte
qu'ils ont connu ça je pense donc je
pense toujours besoin d'un need star ou
de lecteurs a perçu comme tu veux mais
toujours besoin de regards extérieurs
professionnels et intelligent qui vont
te dire
l'autre fait fausse route parce que le
tu vois pilote et d'un depuis mois début
d année des fois aidé d'un pit il recule
que tu as pu et c'est normal et
littoraux besoin de gens qui vont avoir
ce recul l'os pubien envoyer un
manuscrit convaincu à 100% que plus de
ning a changé avec quiconque l'aï lu
mois 7
cette confiance là je la comprends pour
essayer but en vacances là je comprends
pas puis je pense pas que c'est bon pour
le livre je pense pas que c'est bon tu
le dis si personne ne vient pas par le t
shirt et son frère
oui c'est mon ami puis je le redis
pigeons écoutez si vous êtes juste me
dira ce serait un beau patrick c'est
génial point intéressant le commun des
deux mille hectares va me dire ça après
ça mais le corps pendant cinq sont
communs mais je le connais la plupart ce
jeudi je sais que la part des gens qui
me lisent ça c'est cool ça fait chaud au
coeur
mais je veux qu'ils disent stop parce
que u2 la judd a 20 qui a été fait un
bon petit diable je peux pas faire tout
seul même réalisateur de films son
plateau il va faire conseiller par son
directeur photo il va se faire
conseiller par ses comédiens des favoris
moi je ferai demain où je le dirai de
cette manière là
si un réalisateur dit non à tout sinon
mon jeu tu dises domaine puis il ya son
sacre en photo non on tente d'approcher
la proposition de charte je n'aime pas
il fallait 200 films travail d'équipé
c'est de l'écriture c'est que justement
vu tu es le seul écrivain lui tout seul
le pitch est pensé je te manque d'abord
une personne seule et pierrick de wicked
seul mais ça veut pas dire que mam
n'était pas besoin d'un avis extérieur
de bryan à gorge tout à coup
tantôt on parlait du spectacle de cirque
il fallait rendre de plus en plus
intense
ce que ses parts par les graphes et
qu'on aura plus attendues par la
psychologie qui s'est collé de dont les
deux - vient pas sans l'autre pour moi
toutes les tuiles je sais comparons pas
beaucoup de mes cinq graphique on parle
beaucoup de mes scènes de violence qui
sont très très convaincant très réaliste
très bien fait tout ça mais je pense que
le le psychologique de l'avenir avec le
disais tout message très violente très
trash si elle marche comme ça si elle
marche autant que les gens le disent moi
j'espère que c'est le kop ici c'est vrai
si c'est quand c'est sûr que c'est à
cause de toute la technologie qui est
venu avec moi c'est que ces personnages
là qu'est ce que c'est possible qu'ils
en arrivent à poser ces gestes là qu'est
ce qu'ils y subissent se ressemblent je
pense que c'est tout aussi important que
la scène elle-même
ils sont pas bien des films d'horreur ce
qui est beaucoup de certains fonds dès
que certaines scènes violentes font plus
rire que tout autre chose parce que tout
ce qui ressort c'est le côté violent
gore
si ce personnage là on n'y a pas
développé une technologie n'y a pas
développé une personnalité pays régis
l'aspect graphique justement qui qui qui
est dénué d'émotion si ce n'est pas le
reste avec alors moi je pense que tout
doit venir parce que trouver des
manières de celui du monde trouver des
manières de torture et le gard où lé
s'effacer infinie s'effacer le dauphin
louis tu peux tout faire mais ce qui est
ce que ça va être crédible est ce que sa
voix au réalisme vraisemblable est est
ce que le personnage tout ça la
psychologie qui l'a mené à ça est-ce que
ça fait qu'on y croit ce qui est off est
pas de trouver une manière premier qui
font tant de chaînes d'orange avec des
moyens de celui du monde sait pas pas
nier que des cadences sont rendus à 8,1
wind of change pas combien bah oui mais
il va en sortir comme on voyait les
marchés mais pour briller qu'un
sauvetage parce que c'est facile c'est
de l'horreur immature comme on disait
tantôt de droite me suis-je pas si le
monde aime leur art et mathieu lion dois
moi ça m'intéresse plus de 50 1 mais sam
comme un néon stander à 17 ans à 18 ans
à 20 ans à l'horreur immature jamais ça
oui mais moi je trouve que je trouve que
moi je connais un autre étape mais par
une deux conclu pari de dire alors henri
mathieu c'est malsain c'est mauvais
sup moi je trouve ça intéressant sera
soit mais pour moi c'est pas cela très
rares ces métaux sont pas dans le cinéma
moi j'ai et j'ai découvert le cinéma
les premières fois que j'ai vu un film
qui mots qui m'ont bouleversée qui m'a
changé puisque dès qu'il s'est passé de
faire le cinéma autrement c'est qu'il
bildt et j'avais puis je vis ce trop
jeune juste j'avais 12 ans la grosse
différence graphique mais quelque chose
d'artistique là dedans puis quelque
chose de fun témoin comme l'iphone mais
sa frappe au sérieux ce sera pour sa
cuvée que ça passe bien sauf que après
c'est justement ça passe bien mais après
c'est des films téléfilms vraiment fier
funny games est un film vraiment
horrifiante et deux ans et qui ou même
parce que la famille qui est pris à deux
gamins qui viennent s'amuser les autres
tortues psychologiquement et
physiquement
l'aspect psychologique ccpt ou si on
parle d'équilibré qu'on dise façon fin
de race et de shining pour moi que le
coq orange est beaucoup plus bruyant moi
qu'est de shining parce que la vie a
lancé
mais tu vois c'est très personnel et les
choses qu'on trouve en défiant ou non
parce que tu es mons il fournit game
show c'est insupportable que les gens
qui ont été complètement froid devant
cielo qui ont dicté mon grenier senti
j'ai pas compris c'est la tête
psychologique justement qui est
terrifiant mais il ya des gens déjà
qu'ils sont habitués surtout avoir des
films d'horreur surtout sanglant qui me
vanter grand guignol ce que face à un
film psychologique sa pratique ou une
patte est une maturité cinématographique
en tout cas que top que tu développes
garde de se fritter king et regarde
juste cfm lot vous l'êtes pire film le
père film que j'ai vu
piti je pense pas car la catégorie film
d'horreur mais c'est irréversible de
gaspar noé
ouais c'est pis j'ai pu j'ai même pas
voulu regarder la pire c'est la deuxième
personne est encore le viol ou
le viol extincteur l'inspecteur n'ai pas
voulu regarder le vieux le vioxx
moi je trouve complaisance pour qu'ils
prolongent tandis que je trouve qu'on
attend tous sains et qui dira je suis
sûr de lui je suis je suis bon mais le
sun la scène de l'inspecteur c'est sans
doute la personne mise en abyme ça
marche quand ça marche
moi ça m'a traumatisé un peu trop
mations centaines mais ça m'a pas mal je
n'ai jamais arrêté de respirer
d'enseignants devrions donc voyons donc
c'est vraiment là que si ça fait cet
effet là seulement que quelque part ça
marche
cela dit moi gaspar noé jbeil la misère
avec lui je te king
je trouve qu'il joue qu'il cherche trop
tôt jours a choqué le monde dans le
piège de vouloir mettre la barre plus
loin chaque film mais elle existe à la
lance à ses classes mais à cette scène
not a raison ce une scène qui est venu
chercher
oui c'est très très grand il ya des
simples ils avaient des postes et
l'honnêteté de dents dans l'action du
personnage et de l'acteur c'est comme
tellement rien qui fait vivre quelque
chose comme ça c'est insupportable
d'être insupportable comme se disent pas
toujours justes l'aspect gore qui
l'amène parce que l'on ne tout vu des
films gore ou que tu as un gros plein un
scalpel copains oeil de mousseux ça me
fais pas ça me laisse complètement parce
que j'entends le radiateur qui dit à son
caméraman plus proche plus proche m mais
si ça se peut qu'eads du gore et de
l'émotion on annule pas nécessairement à
l'autre mais c'était qu'il est bloqué
pas toujours faciles à trouver et puis
effectivement la scène de l'inspecteur
de réversible fonctionne alors que la
scène de viol que tu as prévu pour moi
le ça fonctionnait plus mais bon c'est
personnel parce que comme lui mosa même
affaire que lui mots et des choses que
je trouve drôle puis quelle autre
personne ne trouve pas drôle d'oiseau
beau leur expliquer de bol analysé de
boldin pourquoi ces drôles ils vont
faire ok yeah right mais trouve pas ça
drôle et des signes de rome roger
bouichou 15 mitcham pourquoi années
qu'elle fournit game commencé terrible
col au gicm habib faye
un contre un mais quand je regarde ça me
fait rien à partir de là c'est très
personnel puis ont tout le monde le
droit d'aimer ce qu'ils veulent t mais
je pense qu'on peut quand même analyse
est l'un des intentions plus
artistiquement intéressantes que
d'autres
puis mois qu'on est du port ou non de
funny games qu'on est russe a terrifié
ou non je pense que c'est facile à
démontrer que artistiquement parlant
pony games est un film plus intéressant
que farhadi de tartines et après ça si
foyer le trading te fais plus pas
personnellement que l'autre ça c'est
subjectif c'est personnel c'est correct
mais reconnaît au moins même système
pony games reconnaît au moins la manière
que c'est fait que c'est intéressant ça
moi aussi ce qu'elle essaie de faire
chaque fois je vois un film même si j'ai
pas aimé ça mais quand je parle de
science fiction pas tous les animaux av
c'est très très froid mais on ne peut
pas ne pas reconnaître que c'est criant
que c'est intelligent que ça amène à
réfléchir à des choses pour reconnaître
les qualités de quelque chose même si on
n'aime pas ça mon des choses pour faire
un peu le lien avec avec ton oeuvre une
des choses d'un qui me fait le plus peur
à moi c'est la projection de la race
humaine bocage avec tes bladerunner le
premier blade runner quétaine révolution
n'est pas niko ah oui parce que le monde
n'en utilise les ducs en a pas ça je les
ai vus j'étais au cégep
je les ai vus 2009 avec 20 des films
avant j'avais un trident moi ça mais ça
va complètement perturbé par ce que
parce que c'était pas si loin de notre
de notre humanité à nous qu'ils
s'amendent qu'est ce que l'espèce de
désir de 2
de croissance économique l'espèce de
désir de devenir est supérieure à 10 m
de s'élever la race humaine qui désirent
qui dort j'ai l'impression au fond de
l'eau font de l'humanité mois en voyant
ça c'est ce qui m'a perturbé le plus
puissant samassa me fait pas moins un
plus grand effet plus fort que n'importe
quel film d'horreur parce que je me dise
c'est dans le sud nous voir le pire de
l'être humain en france et ce pays qui
est capable de faire et d'être toujours
dans la limite du réalisme mais là on
n'y croit pub ça m'a fait peur c'est moi
ce qui m'intéresse le plus dans mes
romans c'est de dire ces deux tickets
quel est le pire qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de pire plein examen pourquoi tu
t'intéresses parce qu'il peut faire de
mieux et parce que ce qui peut faire de
mieux se fait pas des bonnes histoires
ça fais pas d'histoires très intéressant
sauf si un écran vraiment du talent pour
raconter quelque chose de beau début à
une histoire normalement ça prend 1
dames
ok il ya un drame le même une comédie
sentimentale îles andaman neyen
chicanier quelque chose qui marche pas
il peut pas raconter juste là banhart
mais moi oui je veux bien que les jeux
c'est qu'à être humain capable du
meilleur aussi je sais et puis on a des
preuves souvent mais moi je trouve que
fait des bonnes histoires ses cahiers
capable du pire
ça amène à réfléchir sur sa pipe bomb
mon moi ça m'obsède hors jeu pas lutter
contre ça mais oui tu as raison que ceux
ci c'est plus est par un que c'est pour
ça que c'est filmé le couteau qui
rendent en alsace en contexte mais ce
compris que ce personnage là y'avait y
avait ça en lui mais il savait pas
quelque chose qui ressemblait surtout
pourquoi qui rentrent un couteau dans
l'oeil
ces jeux parce qu'il sadique ce point
intéressant il là dessus les moeurs
banal
car aucun cas l'auteur le gaz at her est
plus préoccupé à faire une scène
violente qui a montré pourquoi mon
personnage en arrive à faire ça moi je
trouve que c'est plus le deuxième co qui
est intéressant puis tu vas trouver le
moyen de deux mondes huchette score qu'à
l'angle même date dans mon ramalho très
flamande né il ya quelqu'un qui tous
brigitte serait quelqu'un s'il tente pas
mais y est obligée et dans une cuisine
puis ils tuent à coups de tuer à coups
de toaster je trouve ça bien plus
violent quelqu'un que tu qu'un coup de
toaster que quelqu'un qui va prendre une
lame de rasoir qui vont ils rentrer
tranquillement dans la gorge et 3 qui
fait ça pourquoi qui qui s'amusent à
faire parce que ce n'est plus capable
que je veux je suis méchant
qu'est ce qui incite quelqu'un a tué
quelqu'un de telle manière suivant c'est
l'urgence la panique la peur le
l'instantanéité de l'endroit la
spontanéité josé l'endroit tss alors
sache nous sommes puisque je pense à mon
plus qu'à mal comment laurent du chaos
comment la violence est chaotique plus
que c'est juste une baguette en toi qui
surgit p qui lâche on se plaint alors le
toaster tout à coup devient atrocités
sur les taux ce que je trouve que
l'orage qui dans le quotidien comme ça
ces pays que de voir un autre hymne
dollars ou 1 go pants chaîne s'appuie
dessus quelqu'un à coup de chance
plus capable de voir monde c'est un coup
de chance à ces trous le code c'est trop
cool c'est trop et il a rappelé que
logique est évacuée mais will appear
kaka le père surgi en toi tout peut
devenir menaçant tout peut devenir parce
que l'autre pu contrôler puis lens ça me
fait bien plus par d'accord avec toi que
que de montrer jeu c'est un gars qui
kidnappent du monde puis qu'avec un
tire-bouchon vous voyez arracher un oeil
pis ça c'est du grand guignol
c'est drôle à moins qu'un bon le guilly
fait ça dans une bataille capote
mais quatre fois que toute la mise en
scène et j'avais crevé l'oeil de
quelqu'un avec un tire bouchon
c'est tellement pointe et je compte donc
personnellement avant une fin du mot
avec ses à -2 à -2 but le but c'est ça
qui la rend ce vaillant deuxième degré
oui c'est ça mal face mais ma série mal
fasse cesser de laurent mais c'est de
l'humour aussi
moi je fais des enfants qui sont
vraiment grotesque mais si vous lui
grotesque c'est voulu que le monde rit
donc à chaque fois moins qu'une scène
très violente comme ça dans l'autre
reflets mais pas l'autre flemme aidant
il y aura des morts à manille à
quelqu'un qui plante pin de fer vers
quelqu'un d'un taxi pastorale a vite
fait il là il vise pas trop le chauffeur
de taxi leur soit dans bush
il traverse la bouche d'un coup je veux
seulement la question de tissus qu'ils
sont en train justement de revers du
grand guignol dessus puis j'ai repensé
aux livres tout ce plaisir oies mais ce
livre permet ça le le ton du lit qui est
une espèce de fuite qui est un peu un
jeu en fait mais quelque chose du jeu
vidéo un peu dans ce livre qui permet ça
alors qu'une scène comme ça dans les
sept jours du talion ou dans le vide
ça s'arrêtera pas s'arrêter trop
justement over de top pour le genre de
livre que forcément là aussi qu'est ce
que tu as envie de faire comme comme
celle à l'origine de rock legault
l'emportent dix fois le film reçoit
brendan bell
c'est sûr tu veux c'est ça le but témoin
zaandam aux appels a vu sa frappe au
sérieux ta caisse et ce à des prix
cassés
évidemment toute oeuvre d'art tout neuf
de dates de narrative est un pauvre dans
parce que sponsor mans tout rêve
narrative tout ce qui est négatif et à
autre livre et dès les premières minutes
fouquet un contrat avec le spectateur
c'est à dire voici dans voici ce que je
te propose comme ambiance comme mode et
du prêt à sauter près à ce rôle du fonds
n'était pas prêt à ce rabais fait le pas
et que ce succès arrive et hyper
réaliste puis arriva personnes saines à
la brigade le loto briser le contrat il
te fait non en annonce ce site et passe
alors bon c'était pas ça le but pendant
toute là c'est que ça je pense pour
l'installer assez rapidement puisque le
ce demande à chacun de mes livres
qu'après dix pages pour lecteur sait que
ok on voit de plus dans quelque chose de
très sérieux contre quelque chose qu'on
veut payer à 13 ans est quelque chose de
tenir yassa même affaire en est rien
c'est très cartoon est très ouvert de
tap
l'installation rapidement aussi ça je
pense qu'il faut faire ça avec son
lecteur tout cas tu écris d'aider des
romans comme justement de ces jours du
talion où le vide où c'est plus
psychologique
est-ce que ça t'affecte personnellement
ou tu ressens pas vraiment ce que des
personnages c'est à dire que ou 4 mai
quatre gars des films qui sont basés sur
tes deux livres qui étaient de la mise à
regarder ce ou pas du tout passe-passe
pire parce que j'ai participé au
scénario puis j'ai vu les différentes
étapes donc je découvre pas le film
quand ils se mettent à ta question est
intéressante par rapport à ce que je
ressemble parce que c'est comme comme
contradictoires d'un côté de mettre en
place des personnages pour voir qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent s'en tirer en même
temps fou tu protèges puis moi j'écris
dérive extrêmement je peux pas vraiment
me mettre dans la peau de quelqu'un qui
reçoit un coup d'argent dans les banques
le jeu s'est passé quoi savoir dans le
vent mais j'ai plus été de mieux
approcher le plus possible mentalement
il toujours aussi je serai là c'est
toujours aussi de que la mécanique de sa
peine d'être casté fonctionne donc ça
fonctionne certain recul fait que j'ai
toujours conscience en écrivant un livre
toujours conscient que de la mécanique
de quelqu'un la scène et finit pas
perturbé pendant trois semaines je peux
et j'arrive pas toute la soirée remonte
sur qu'est ce que j'écris là me
débarrasse assez rapidement mentalement
je passe à autre chose
jusqu'où peut passer facilement parce
que j'écris aussi avec cette distance là
mais faut pas que ça paraît à ce projet
de loi le plus possible un pic
émotivement alors qu'au fond c'est très
cartésien comment cet écrit il foule
donne l'impression du canard qui que la
rafle au titre que tout va bien mais
quand souley les départs il faut aller
au mont du fait que tout est très
chorégraphié tout est très technique
mais faut pas que ça paraisse vous soit
l'émotion qui semble emporter mais que
ceux ci c'est cet équidé bloc faut que
le seuil de trouver le nom jeu pour
perturber parce que nos contrats comme
je dis saliba mois + plus on dirait
qu'on avance dans le temps plus
et possibilités web grossistes
plus hell.com devient un terrifiant
points c'est drôle parce qu'elles
pointent comme je parle de reconnaître
dans le c300 savoir parce que j'ai ce
sens en 2009 c'était pas le masque aussi
existait il n'était pas très connu mais
je connaissais proxénète me voir
aujourd'hui qui me disent ah et est elle
programmée
tu écris ce drone est un fait mais je ne
savais pas et que dans le fond
j'ai compris c'est beau que j'ai compris
mais je me suis dit pourquoi ce
existerait pas pourquoi stone qui
atteint fois qu'une caméra quête pas
pourquoi car on le savait déjà il y
avait des rues 10 40 à se reconnaître
que des gens avaient filmé des meurtres
si c'est bon mais moi j'ai pensé que ce
fait organiser et ce sera peut-être pas
autant que dans les points comme mais
quand même il existe seulement une
réparation est pas loin
ben est ce ce que il ya des criminels
qui ont été ré amenés à contrôler ça
parce qu'il ya du cash affaires puis je
vais montrer justement que les vrais
baisse des points comme dans la fin du
roman c'est ce que je montre c'est que
c'est pas des fous c'est pas des cds
businessman le goal qui rencontra fin le
1 des bois ce parce qu'il y ait
plusieurs bars et des actionnaires
puis c'est l'intérêt semaine passée site
là ils vont même pas regardé ça il
trouve ça assez horrible ça mais il ya
du cash affaires puis à faire avec ses
fantasmes qui existe est nouveau il faut
que moi je propose un service dati et
cette froideur par rapport à ça je pense
que ça se peut ben oui je pense pas que
des idées l'idée pense pas que les
grands criminels sont je pense que des
hommes d'affaires justement qui qui qui
contrôle des choses criminels sans eux
mêmes et des adeptes de ces crimes là
mais c'est une business et je vais
montrer qu'effectivement c'est possible
que internet le drap net pourrait être
de venir ça n'est peut-être une auprès
de certaines personnes pensaient pas que
ce match banques font de l'argent avec
la donne est ce que c'est la preuve que
l'imaginer c'est pas la mort mais ses
organes à la fois surpris je tiens pas
mais c'est sûr que oui c'est sûr qu'il
ya moyen d'avoir des sous groupes des
groupes en dessous peut-être je me tiens
informé auprès de policiers pour près
des deux spéciales informatique
comment aller sur des sites illégal
censé reprendre l'on m'a parlé de
tournant par les bombes tous ces trucs
là on m'a dit que je t'aime à lille il y
là je me rappelle plus tellement c'est
tellement longtemps mais que weeds peu à
être des savoirs richard gere voir
souvent pour justement cas pas la partie
malgré tout qu'on le trouvait quelque
part on s'envoie le pipe sûrs ils
changent de place souvent souvent pour
passer un panier alors on passe dix ans
qui a dit ça c'est sûr si ça marche plus
organisé en corse et sûrement encore
plus difficile la pomme avait dit tu es
patrick ne peut pas écrire sur google
vous seriez ou à l'époque peut pas
écrire non mais tu peux même pas écrire
enfant de 10 ans torturé pour ça va
paraître du pauvre est lancé la police a
cessé
il faut que tu reçois des ddd code dans
des images le code doit être écrite y
créer un code selon ça veut dire que si
tu tombes sur la torture ou sur de la
pornographie juvénile
la pornographie jeune et l'on s'attaque
spawn fille de 25,6 me dit dubuc qui
mangent reçues sont là comme ça elle
avait 14 ans on parle devrait prendre
effet
c'est organisé peut pas être tombé là
dessus par hasard ça se peut plus la
seule équipe qu'ils y ont découvert
qu'un site rabin je tombe et là dessus
par hasard non à 90 au voulu aller le
chercher activement recherché activement
et renseigné puis et c'est ça qui me
fait pas et c'est peut-être mon roman a
fait que fait le plus peur au monde à
cause de sa légende et woippy capoter
hands on se fait réaliser que ça se
passe c'est de loin à plus tard on
encense à d'autres plus maintenant à mal
et pas que des bons dits par ce vraiment
qu'on peut voir des choses de même sur
internet
mais pourquoi pas
quoi pas dit si le free for all internet
là c'est le cyan notre but fins de
buffet la can au cse s'est c'est quoi
ces c manute acquis et qui avait fait la
vidéo qui avait été drafté accès simple
et terrible existe encore c'est sûr mais
c'est vrai que quelqu'un qu'elles sont
en ce moment puisque du cash avec ça
puis le geek et que tu es les musulmans
l'eau en nouvelle zélande fait qu'il
faisait à facebook live l'année et là
c'est notre audit soit qui spectacular
is la sas sas et où il en tabarnouche
deviennent vedette peu importe comment
mais devine être même en seconde seule
chose à faire avec ça c'est clair parce
que c'est si j'avais écrit levé
d'aujourd'hui j'écrirai pas de la même
manière la même manière ça va encore
plus loin il ya moyen et mode est morte
live
je pensais pas à 100 et qui va le sait
que ce n'est pas le truc live en direct
lorsque c'était pas très à la mode mais
aujourd'hui si quelqu'un faisait
hell.com affirme aujourd'hui puis ça se
passait de nos jours je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'il ait assisté live à tel
événement bon tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui est qu'elle récupère mais en
fait je les fait face à ce jeu des fêtes
avec il y aura des morts je ris pas plus
mais il ya quelque chose il y aura des
marques et qui est faible ou fait-il si
les derniers mois qu'il dernière - qui
ressemble au facebook live le way ouais
bon tu vois ça c'est fait cech une
question
je suis pas 100 % informés sur ce
dossier là mais je veux quand même voir
ton opinion
il ya eu non je sais que ton côté la
poursuite le long de deux semaines pour
je suis pas au courant de j'ai pas lu
l'oeuvre je pollue les passages je sais
pas quel point c'est une version trash
de sel et gretel de pédophilie agression
sexuelle et viol et puis voilà mais à la
fin je ne parie pas trop quand même
c'est pas que ça lui arrive c'est une
page sur sa glorifie pas du tout le
c'est patrick de dire regardez comment
c'est cool c'est très très très très
très graphique
est-ce que c'est nécessaire aixois
graphique comme ça c'est personnel comme
j'attends tôt est ce que c'est de bon
goût non ce synode question la question
est pour l'heure la question pour savoir
si bon goût pas citer nécessaire de tout
ce qu'ils réfutent ou non la question
c'est en risque et son encouragement
la réponse est non puis deux c'est de la
fiction
excuse moi de censurer la fiction de
légiférer sur la fiction ça me fait pas
moins je sais que ça concerne uniquement
la pédophilie mais malgré tout je dis
hein quoi c'est pire de montrer une
scène de pédophilie qu'une femme qui
s'étend sur email océane à 30,1 et moi
je reviens me dis que 1,1 go qui
distingue au sein d'esprit que cette
scène ne va pas donner pédophiles
pédophiles qui cette scène loyers déjà
pédophiles mais qu il va trouver quelque
chose de mieux que d'autres et que je
dois mieux que ça existe des textes ou
des bandes dessinées à la femme et c'est
peut-être que ce genre de textes ou
images le qui sont pas encore la vraie
face à près de la mairie ils répandent
en écoutant même en fiction il existe
pire que seul il ya des bandes dessinées
européenne n'a que je te jure dépend d
erratique que je te jure qu'on
parce que ce soit écrit la rolls des
personnages mais que facilement à croire
qu'ils n'ont pas 18 ans l'homme est là
sefyu fait que puits mauger repos qui
parce que je vois qu'avec des playes
mais j'ai lu des affaires aux pires que
ça est une plante femme qui s'est plaint
et selon l'article de loi
alors qu'est ce qui va avec ça puis la
fille de loi dit que quand c'est pour la
rend plus il peut avoir une
une exception fait que moi je pense que
je peux faire des pronostics mais y
opposeraient manger j'espère qu'on va on
va servir de ce colloque
pour me rendre la loi claire eelv avait
deux choses
on verra la loi car on voit des bons en
fiction pis c'est pas de vérifier on en
parle plus on peut pas se plaindre de ça
nous avons mené durcir la loi plus en
plus durs puis là ça va peut-être
déborder sur dix clubs ce sont d'autres
affaires à travers les visites ils vont
arrêter ça existe déjà la grossière mais
qu'est ce qu'ils appellent l obscénité
c'est là que moi c'est ça que j'ai passé
que ou savoir et glisse une fois pour
toutes ce colloque ce qu on va dire ça
va faire en fiction laissez moi
tranquille le monde peut faire ce qu'il
veut en fiction c'est pas vrai un
nouveau puits c'est pas d'encouragements
plus ou alors ça va venir ça va créer un
précédent qui savent ouvrir la porte
plus large et moi c'est cette partie du
crêpa qui va décider tous comme la paix
notamment la peine de mort si c'était
toujours des codes 1 go qui au violet 14
en fait qu'ils au dessus et après on
serait pas très triste cette personne ne
m'a mais à partir de quel crime et a
passé de quelques hectares que c'est que
la liga briques ou laurent quelqu'un qui
mérite la peine de mort quelqu'un ya
mérite pas les taux de suivi de
personnes d'amérique pop up 9/9 ça y est
tu as mérité qui va décider ça hein sûr
que c'est inapplicable cc et en fixe -
de pareilles à partir de combien de
litres de sang quelque chose devient
insupportable à partir de combien de
meurtres de combien de cris d'agonie de
combien de minutes de souffrance
physique comment comment qu'on va
appliquer ça donc je les trouve des
lignes est trop flou et je pense que
c'est à cause de ça que que ça passera
pas un mais c'est quand même terrible ce
qui se passe là parce qu'il ya quand
même un gars un hôtel dans qui étaient
arrêtés qu'on eut arrêté chez lui à
cause des cris une scène d'un affect the
violée dans la fiction sur un roman de
jeu pas combien de pages qui en plus
montrent que c'est de savoir que deux
minutes à faire arrêter chez vous pour
ça c'est quand même épouvantable
ceux qui disent que lui de triper il
s'agissait de pistes et n'entraient pas
garanti qui très posh connaît le milieu
caennais l'éditeur je connais le gosse
il ne trie pas il peut même plus
entendre
comment c'est que là il vit un cauchemar
vie cégep en pente le pc le titre de
l'article c'était son nom arrêtez
production on le sait les gens lisent
les grands magasins de quoi les parents
les parents des amis de tes enfants qui
partagent des sondages sais pas du tout
si ça n'a aucun sens à la ccc dans la
cct le fait que n'en est rien dans le
fond ce que l'on m'a pris du temps à la
trouve pas drôle non plus pire oui mais
ça aussi il poursuivi pour publier ça
ouais et que non non non non non c'est
moi moi je trouve que ça crée un
précédent qui peut être dangereux c'est
fou c'est foutu dire que c'est un livre
comme ça est enlevé les tablettes alors
qu'on peut encore se procurer bat exec
issad le marquis de sade pour garder le
même
lolita de nabokov qui est un livre sur
un gain qui tripent sur une petite fille
pendant le livre au complet puis oui
c'est même pas plainte
ce qui se vend à l'encouragement à tf1
ça finit pas une personne qui est triste
c'est pas graphique
ces graphiques la dame qui se plaignent
ça n'aurait pas existé qu'est ce que ça
vous fait que ça existe encore ça vous
dérange quand il est tombé là dessus
pourquoi mais pourquoi tu as acheté sa
première balle à quoi tu tapes à pied
des avertissements puis à tout là bas
c'est parce que quelque chose qui existe
qui te dérange existe que ça doit
d'exister et de vivre avec le fait que
des choses qui nous dérange avec
lesquels nous sommes pas moralement
d'accord qui doit d'exister
puis le cette dame l'a dit ça peut
donner des idées au monde est là
faudrait s'informer ça ça marche pas de
même esprit humain c'est déjà aussi et
qui est intéressant ce genre loeb qui
vaut des fois un petit peu plus loin un
petit stress c'est comme le black metal
le plus trash ou le plus violent qui
peut trouver parce qu'ils commencent à
écouter ceux du premier coup mais dit
commencer comment sont adéquates plus
haut le second mandat un gros bang death
metal l'apprend
parfois la faute d'entente des limites
l'amendement du groupe norvégien
attention le dos qui se prennent un peu
trop sérieux le sont dangereux mais voit
questionner les modes et des groupes
métal moins connectés en masse de métal
quand j'étais jeune piquante pas la vie
aux broncos par la black sabbath 15 par
là vous ne prenez pas au sérieux j'ai
jamais ça serait pour moi je me rappelle
jamais eu le goût d'aller brûler une
église par octet black sabbath le jeu ça
cool de voir l'équivalent de films d'art
en mettant de la musique cool je vais
plus au premier degré de folie du monde
sacrifier des vierges tout seul dit
faire confiance aux gens aussi amener
quelqu'un qui est sain d'esprit voit pas
virer fou parce qu'il ya un temps de
crier je fais un sac un scientifique qui
parurent longtemps j'ai lu l'article sur
les sur les métalleux justement pour ça
dit que ça rend pas plus violent que ce
matin là au contraire ça ces gens ne
sont plus d'aucune annonce souvent les
metal ce qui coûte le métal c'est
souvent d'aidé et des outsiders un peu
c'est déjà je crois qu'ils se
reconnaissaient pas dans les groupes
culpa moi je t'ai pas des coups là mon
école fait que mahmoud communauté de
métalleux on avait l'impression
justement d'être un peu rebelle en
écoute à ça au fait qu'il ya quelque
chose là dedans il ya vraiment une danse
très dix morts dont 7 et audi est comme
ça qu'on se penche de notre importance
l'épaule côté violent pour nous rendre
violent qu'on veut se venger du monde de
ce post apo solide et par tout moyen
il ya un cas qui meurent fait
questionner titres phares c'est le cas
de claude cac 40 jc de sané kubrick ou
que lui-même décidé de retirer son film
disney mots parce qu'il y avait une
vague de criminalité qu'imiter tadic
avait déjà il ya des criminels qui se
déguisait comme les personnages de
craquage
mais ces gens là est ce qu'ils jouent
aux échecs chez eux a mal fait mme
lahaie ce qui faisait de spyro graff
l'appui
les dessins de licorne transports c'est
qu'elle y ont trouvé comme un espèce de
symbole pour ce tweak roulante réseau
mais moi je pense que ces gens là
étaient déjà des criminels l'avancé mais
oui c'est mais non c'est ça mais oui
c'est troublant et clank orange est un
cas extrême d'accord extrême parce que
et du point de vue du personnage puis le
personnage qui fait ils trouvent ça cool
et à la fin quartier guiry guy anguilles
mais le monde devient pire que lui fait
que l'outil devient quasiment totalement
pitié de ces criminels le film
extrêmement tordu puis mon seul mes
films préférés à vie parce que justement
ce côté de torture est intéressant
examiner et puis bon mais évidemment que
si j'étais s cube break puis j'avais vu
mettons la tg body qu'un livre peut pas
espérer des gens s'étaient pas déjà un
peu fauqué évidemment que la police me
plaît pas mais m6 sénégal
venez nous rejoindre à telle adresse que
quelque chose que vous intéresser
j'arrive là pour me distingue ce cas par
contre nos frères en syrie regardez son
appartement qu'il ya des pages de mes
livres coller ces murs que nous ferons
tout le moins qu'un siège qui brûle en
dessous ça doit être bien trop matelas
ça doit être très traumatisant puis je
sais pas comment je vivrai avec ça et
que je peux comprendre que kubrick a
fait ça marshall un peu moins mais ce le
fait d'être complètement objectif en
lotion commençons pro plus rien faire
parce que tu as toujours inspiré du
monde et quand ça t'affecte dans ton
corps catus et l'accueil hôtelier dirait
quelqu'un psychopathe qui a imité lives
qu'elle sache jan ausma ce montant du
film et livre pour les mauvaises raisons
mais je sais pas ce qui fait que ça va
pas et dans ce temps là et si je faisais
face à ça j'espère que ça m'arrivera pas
parce que ça doit te remettre en
question entendue et ce par la force des
choses il y avait une vague de personnes
qui intègrent crime déguisé en clown
pour attirer les enfants moi comme dans
ceux de stephen king pour durer
longtemps va pas durer longtemps annoncé
ça c'est puis pense pas que ça peut
durer longtemps non plus en grande
bretagne le côté le côté on se déguise
commun tout en blanc avec jack strapi le
chapeau haut de forme libre
mais même si là que tu vois qu'il y ait
un effet mode les criminels on dit des
psychopathes peuvent subir une certaine
mode mais je je
enfin police cas par cas par des mots
mais des criminels des ddd petit con
mais je sais 6
alors les géants clown en fait quand
même pas déguiser en clown
c'est ce truc là qu'ils ont rendus fous
je dis n'importe quoi d'autre aurait pu
arriver à n'importe quel autre film
n'est pas vu le mauvais fait mon mauvais
moment mais sinon il n'aurait vu un
autre mauvais livres au mauvais moment
mais il ne les lui un autre mais encore
là je le répète ça tu arrives ici comme
cinéaste comme autant le vix qui peut
pas séparer les motifs de les motifs de
la terre et c'est rationnel remettre en
question le dédouane êtres humains le
fait que près très différents sols c'est
tu parlais en tout des bulls et nous
permet de revenir un peu ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure par rapport au fait que
les oeuvres la littérature affecte
couleuvres les ordres affectant
nécessairement les gens ont compris les
convaincus mais admettons si on prend
telle les souffrances du jeune werther
quand c'est sorti puis qui avait d y
retrouver des jeunes hommes
suicider avec télé poche à l'extérieur
comme dans le personnage se livre le
avait déjà des déjà très romantique des
gens rentraient pas mal de vie c'est
exact sauf qu est ce que ces gens leur
aurait pu
éviter ce sort le site était pas tombé
sur un livre comme celui là le suicide
c'est un cas très particulier c'est ça
ma blonde me parle souvent parce que
psychologue pierre a dit à chaque fois
qu'on parle de suicide
même pour le dénoncer une vague de
suicides point de soucis de monde
juste le fait d'en parler d'armes et a
dit mais qu'est ce qu'on fait on en
reparle port ont fait pas de dénoncer
parce qu'il ya peut-être pleinement se
serait suicidé aussi mais qui l'ont pas
fait quand sa soeur mais ça on ne sait
pourquoi on a 3 à 6 ans et que moi je me
rappelle quand j'écris le le vide
il ya eu une
et oui il faut être responsable quand
même qu'au montage je vais emmener c'est
pas parce que tu es un autre fait de la
fiction que ce notaire déresponsabiliser
c'est à dire que moi tout ce que dans
mes livres je capable de justifier
pourquoi je les fait c'est quoi ce qui
est important dans le vide il ya une
secte on sait que mais le principal
amène les gens amènent des groupes de
jeunes a à dire le suicide est la
solution ont pu amener les gens se
suicider
et je me suis dit c'est au tce ça parce
que ce qui est très convaincant plus
c'est quelqu'un qui prenne et prenez mon
lit plus bas coût dont il ya peut-être
raison pour moi c'est clair que je monte
quand même à la fin du roman quelques
kills roma jusqu'au bout ils comprennent
que le suicide n'est pas la solution
et puis moi je pense pas que c'est faux
que je sois fidèle à moi même aussi je
pense pas c'était un auteur décrit de
façon très sérieuse et très convaincu
que les vues vaut pas la peine qu'on
devrait tous se suicider mais soit
conséquent puis va se suicider trouvera
le dire c'est un défi trop des autorités
de fait trop longtemps qui dit
l'humanité est assez merdique tout ça
mais bon en même temps je vis quand même
plutôt mon compte mais stick un roman où
ni liste au point que ça se lit je la
seule issue c'est de mourir quatre
autres dans des cocktails heureux pour
tout 5 à 7 pour la gagne pour sa très
conséquent il ya des choses qui ont été
conséquents que le cobain était
conséquent c'est triste une tragédie
système en 4 4 4 sur garde son oeuvre
piqué tout cas ce que fait chou blanc
même le chanteur de voyons les colocs
dédé fortin est écoute d'art novembre la
dernière tournée en novembre tabarre nos
chats il fait le pôle gaulle à ses
avants pour ben là c'est encore moi qui
aime la vie malgré tout je vais faire un
roman qui montrent que la ville et les
gens sont décevants des fois tout ça
m'effraie pas qu'à la fin du vide je
donne l'impression que susciter une
solution parce que je n'y crois pas je
pense pas que c'est sopi mais c'est de
la fiction
on parle de soi on revient ce qu'on les
entend on par grain de ce web de ses
valeurs de ses convictions puis je serai
pas un livre moi qui m'a dit que le
suicide est une bonne idée peut faire
rouler sur un personnage qui lui dicte
une bonne idée le spa nos personnages
mais le vide par du québec au complet
parle d'une société et donne une image
par la société a lancé jeudi que la
solution la société se suicident leur
poulailler au bout de mon idée puis je
le fasse et je le fais pas parce que
l'on aime la vie malgré tout il fallait
que ça ressorte un peu aussi ah c'est
pour ça qu'à la fin 2-2
il y a
une lueur d'espoir carmen de moi des
gens qui ont lu le vide qui m'ont dit
des jeunes surtout de 25 années qui
m'ont dit moi j'ai eu le veloster une
période là j'étais en hostie être
l'humanité j'étais allée made for cloud
of the world à mon dieu je délire se
ramène à ce moment-là ça pas du tdf et
non abonnés une drive parce que leurs
collègues leur santé je voyais qu'il y
avait quelqu'un qui avait fait quelque
chose de cette colère lundi le canaliser
dans un roman dans la fiction dont
construit avec ta rage de construit
quelque chose ça m'a donné le goût de
faire la même affaire sa sauce inter
qu'il fallait m'enfin c'est pas de lait
cru du monde cessé de s'y amuser mouche
à retourner aux études il y avait des
bouts témoignages bon évidemment je
pense pas que c'est une bonne d'élise en
général des gens déprimés qu'ils lisent
ça vaut peut-être prisé des médias max
heyes à aider tous les rom as jusqu'au
bout je n'encourage pas le suicide
je ne fais pas ça le romantisme allemand
était quelque chose ou le suicide était
une espèce de sera de littéraires
extrêmement la mode le mal de vivre et
tout ça et est ce que les otages étaient
dépositaires ou y croyait vraiment je ne
sais pas bien en oxyde veillerai ya donc
sa dette par poesy terreur puis les gens
en plus était moins fort mais
qu'aujourd'hui alors oui pas tel que ces
livres long on s'entend que quelqu'un
qui disait je ne verrais ça
je pense que c'était des gens quand même
souffrance je ne pense pas que quelqu'un
qui avait la joie de vivre qui vit sa
volonté d après moi je pense qu on
convint sont des convaincus
je pense que notre exception je pense
pas aller voir publier quelque chose que
tu fais à jamais jamais pensé à ça tout
ça existe là mais je pense pas qu'un
film ou un livre changer une société je
pense pas c'est ce serait le fun non
mais c'est pas grave le dire on fait pas
ça non plus on fait ça parce qu'on en a
le besoin de l'écrire puis à des gens
qui vont lire parce qu'à ce moment-là y
ont besoin de lire ça ça peut quand même
y faire réfléchir et évoluer un peu mais
si on écrit à chaque fois quelque chose
en disant je respecte la société va
changer grâce à mon livre ses prisons de
sur tarnos je suis prétentieux au monde
où tout à fait patrick senécal merci
beaucoup d'avoir été leur merci c'était
super
sinon le projet de rama qui voit sortir
à l'automne prochain si tout va bien
j'ai pas dit il ça parle de ma part de
la mort mon genre qu'apparemment il
savoir le sujet water est ce que
d'autres projets
paris cinéma qui regarde bien c'est
tellement certain puis à la bd va sortir
en deux groupes de 200 pages pascalis
avait passé près tout adapté des
ablations en aura pas de limites des
premiers à l'acheter
merci